[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: Good morning.
Welcome family and friends
of the MIT graduating
class of 2007.
[CHEERING]
MCGANN: We're coming to you
live from this grand stage
here at MIT'S Killian
Court, where even right now,
they are bringing up
those degrees that in just
three short hours,
the graduates will
be receiving those hard-earned
degrees right behind me.
My name is Matt McGann.
I'm the associate director
of admissions here at MIT.
I'm also a graduate of
MIT, of MIT class of 2000.
So it wasn't very long
ago that I remember taking
the walk across the stage.
And as an admissions officer,
I read the applications
of many of these students
who we'll be seeing today.
I know them well, and they
are excellent and world class.
And it is a privilege to be
here celebrating them today.
VIELMA: Welcome.
My name is Karina Vielma.
I am also a graduate
of MIT, class of 2001.
I am assistant dean in the MIT
Office of Minority Education.
Commencement is a
very special time
at MIT, a time where the entire
institute community comes
together to celebrate
the accomplishments
of a remarkable group of
young men and young women.
We will be visiting with
you for the next 90 minutes
as we await the arrival
of our guests of honor.
They are currently gathering
in the Johnson Athletic Center
on the west side
of campus, and you
should be able to see
them on the big screen.
They will be joining us
out here in Killian Court
at about 9:50 AM.
MCGANN: I'm sure you'll
agree that Killian Court is
a grand setting for what will
be MIT'S 141st commencement
exercises.
This is the only
space at MIT that
is fit for 13,000 people
will be here today.
It will be a beautiful day.
The National Weather
Service is predicting
a perfect day-- no rain,
highs of 77 degrees,
and partly cloudy.
I cannot imagine a more perfect
day for commencement exercises.
Killian Court is also a
space that doesn't always
have these chairs out here.
During the school year,
it's a great place
to study, to play
Ultimate Frisbee,
and actually, this
is the place where
our MIT students began
their MIT career,
as well as will end it today.
So just behind me,
below that great dome,
in front of those
great columns, was
where they gathered four short
years ago for their freshmen
photograph.
Do you remember your
freshman photograph, Karina?
VIELMA: Yes, I do, Matt.
I remember there was a
hack placed on us too,
since we were in
that class of 2001.
So we had a hack for the
Space Odyssey 2001 movie
our here in Killian Court.
MCGANN: And of course, Killian
Court and the Great Dome
behind us is a classic setting
for MIT'S pranks, which we call
hacks, as you probably know.
That Great Dome behind us
has hosted a police car--
a full scale police car with
working, flashing lights,
and coffee and--
VIELMA: And donuts, I believe.
MCGANN: And donuts, yes, indeed.
And one year ago,
there was a fire truck
also placed atop that
Dome with a giant ladder.
One of my favorites was when
they turned this Great Dome
behind us into R2-D2.
If you kind of
squint, it looks kind
of like that domed
head of R2-D2.
Do you have a favorite hack
that happened here at MIT?
VIELMA: Not really, Matt, but
I do have many, many memories
of walking through Killian
Court my Course 18,
which is mathematics, my Course
18 classes over in building
two, which is over here
by the giant screen.
And it's a great
privilege to be out here.
Because as you walk and--
as you're walking to class, you
realize the hard-earned degree
that not everybody receives.
It's only people who
graduate from MIT.
We don't give out
any honorary degrees.
So it is a great honor.
MCGANN: In the
admissions office,
we like to say that there's only
one way to earn an MIT degree,
and that's the hard way.
And the graduates today
are proof of that.
So our goal for
the next hour or so
is to celebrate the members
of the MIT Class of 2007.
We'll show some video clips
of MIT students in action.
We'll interview some
family and friends.
Plus a sampling
of this year's MIT
graduates, we'll
interview them live over
at the Johnson Athletic Center,
and that'll be pretty exciting.
And we'll take a
look at them as they
prepare for their wonderful
opportunities ahead.
VIELMA: Video coverage
of these proceedings
are being webcast live
throughout the world.
Those of you here
in Killian Court
will be able to watch a
recorded version of the webcast
from your home or
office computers.
This year, we will
also be offering
a podcast of the ceremony.
So if you wish, you're welcome
to download Commencement 2007
to your iPod or
personal digital device.
In February of last year, MIT
began producing a video podcast
magazine with the purpose of
capturing and communicating
the richness and diversity
of the MIT experience.
We call this endeavor ZigZag.
I love that name.
Each ZigZag episode
features stories
of student life,
research, special events,
interesting people, and
the occasional hack,
as we were discussing.
We will be showing you
sample episodes of ZigZag
throughout the morning.
The first episode was
podcast last summer
and is hosted by my
colleague and fellow MIT
alum, Matt McGann.
He's a celebrity on campus.
MIT benefits from a vibrant and
very loyal, committed alumni.
You will see the 50th reunion
class, the Class of 1957,
proudly displaying their
red coats later this morning
walking down Killian Court,
as this next story explains.
MCGANN: Coming to you from
the Stat Center at MIT,
my name is Matt McGann,
and this is ZigZag.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Commencement week is
always a special time
of year for our
graduating students,
but it's also an
occasion for our alumni
to reflect upon how MIT
has shaped their lives.
Many graduates come
back to campus for Tech
reunions to keep up with
current events at the Institute
and to catch up
with old friends.
Tech Reunions 2006
was a festive affair,
attracting a record number
of alumni and guests
participating in a rich
assortment of activities.
PRESENTER: Welcome.
Or should I say to many of
you, welcome back to MIT.
GARVIN: Alumni come back
for a number of reasons.
Some people come to
reconnect with old friends.
And a lot of people come
to have an opportunity
to meet the people they
never really got to know.
There are a number of
highlights of Tech Week.
One of them is our
traditional Tech Night
at Pops, which we've
been doing for 106.
We buy out Symphony Hall.
And classes from the senior
class to the oldest alumni
come, and we have a great time.
Technology Day, which brings
together a series of faculty,
is a wonderful
opportunity to get up
to date on what's
going on at MIT.
And during Tech Week, we have
one of our three times a year
broadcast for the
Enterprise Forum,
which is based in
Kresge Auditorium
and then broadcast
around the world.
One of the nice things
about Tech reunions
is that you can cut
across all the classes,
and you have an opportunity
to bring together somebody
from the fifth reunion class and
somebody from the 40th reunion
class.
And they can talk to each other.
They can find out how
they built their company.
They're great events.
Everyone who comes
wants to come again.
They'd recommend it to a friend.
So I think the
important thing is
it would be even better if we
can get a larger percentage
of each class participating.
MCGANN: For the Class of
1956, this year's reunion
was especially
memorable, as 2006
is the year they
finally get to don
the legendary red jacket,
bestowed upon every MIT
50-year reunion class.
BLOTNER: My name is Mal Blotner.
And I was in Course 10.
You know that we do
it by numbers here.
ALUMNI: Course 7.
ALUMNI: Course 16.
ALUMNI: Course 10.
MCGANN: How did it
feel when you first
got to put on the red jacket?
CHIHOSKI: Well, exciting.
And this is my dad's red jacket.
My dad was Class of '28
also in civil engineering.
GOODWILL: The last time
I was here was 1988.
My son graduated from here.
So it was a--
it brings back a
lot of memories.
MATSA: I worked with a
Whirlwind computer, which
was a whole room full of tapes
and all kinds of other gadgets.
INTERVIEWER: Do you remember how
many women were in the class?
WAHL: From what I have
been told and we've
tried to figure out, if you only
count the entering freshmen,
it was 13.
And then, eight graduated.
BROWN: In '56, there weren't
many people of color.
I came to MIT
primarily because I
wanted make sure that no one
ever doubt my credentials.
And that has helped.
FRANK: I've been
waiting 50 years
for the privilege of
wearing this jacket
and walking down
in the procession.
50 years I've been
waiting for this.
What a kick!
MCGANN: After
graduation week, you
might think that things would
slow down a bit here at MIT,
but that's not
entirely the case.
Almost before we had a chance
to catch our breath, 50 K
through 12 educators
arrived on campus
for the week-long
Science and Engineering
Program for Teachers, or SEPT.
We sat down with the founder
of SEPT, Professor Ron
Latanision, who told us
more about the program's
educational mission.
LATANISION: The origin of
the program and the intention
of the program has always
been to provide teachers
with the perspective
of a MIT faculty
on what science and
engineering means
in terms of our whole
standard of living.
So our goal today
is not only to deal
with the question of technical
literacy in the broadest sense
but also to encourage young
people, through their teachers,
to pursue their interest
or to develop interest
in science and
technology, and to become
part of the infrastructure
of the future in the United
States.
PROFESSOR: Good morning.
And welcome to MIT on the behalf
of MIT'S Physics Department.
LATANISION: The program
runs for a full week.
We describe it at the outset
as being typical of the MIT
educational experience,
and that is, as a drink
from a fire hose.
MODIC: I definitely had a
biology fire hose yesterday.
I had no clue what
was being said.
And that's OK.
I don't think that
you can ever come
into a program
like this expecting
to absorb 100% of what's said.
And they don't expect
us to, I don't think.
I hope not.
[LAUGHS]
BANTOE: Each day is-- it's
literally mentally exhausting.
By the time you get
to the afternoon,
it's like you've gotten so
much information, so much
useful information, actually.
PROFESSOR: You see here the
primary red on the outside,
blue on the inside.
And here, you see the secondary.
WALKER: We talk about
rainbows, something
as simple and
beautiful as a rainbow,
and how a rainbow is
created and looking
at the mathematical
aspects of a rainbow.
So you'll never look at
a rainbow again the same.
LATANISION: We have
thought over the years
it would be very useful if we
could export what we have done
on campus to other locations.
And so this year,
we are actually
broadcasting the
program in this summer
live to over the internet.
There are a group
of about 35 teachers
who are in a classroom at the
University of Rhode Island,
and they're participating
interactively
with the teachers who
are on our campus.
RENEHAN: My hope is that I
can take this information back
to my students.
And when I'm in calculus
class or pre-calculus
and they ask me, when am
I ever going to use this?
Then, I can give them a real,
live application that, look,
this is research that
is currently going on.
And this is how it can be used
and applied in the real world.
MCGANN: As regular
viewers of ZigZag
know, for the past
several years,
the MIT campus has become
a preferred nesting site
for mating red-tailed hawks.
This year, for the second time,
AMPS, MIT'S media production
group and the
producer of ZigZag,
was able to videotape and
webcast the maturation
process of two checks.
On Easter weekend,
these eggs were
cracked open, not by children
in search of chocolate,
but by two baby hatchlings
in search of space,
space to stretch and grow and
eat and grow and grow and grow.
Nourished by a
plentiful supply of food
from their expert
hunter parents,
the chicks seemed to
double in size each week.
Soon, a global
audience was enjoying
their day-to-day activities.
A virtual community
gathered around the nest
as hawk watchers traded
observations and insights
on the Hawk Cam blog.
Together, we all shared in the
excitement of sibling rivalry,
parents being parents, curious
first wanderings from the nest,
and, as graduation
week approached,
their maiden flights.
We wish our fledglings
the best as they
explore the world beyond MIT.
We were fortunate to
watch them grow and learn.
And we also learned from them.
That's all the time
we have for now.
From the Stata Center
at MIT, I'm Matt McGann.
Thank you for watching ZigZag.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARVIN: That was a
great ZigZag episode.
Now, let's check in on what
our guests are-- of honor
are up to.
We have a student on the street,
Reporter Allie [? Poshay, ?]
over in Johnson Athletic Center.
[? POSHAY: ?] Hi, Karina.
VIELMA: Hello, Allie.
How are things over there?
[? POSHAY: ?]
Everybody is buzzing.
There's an incredible energy
down here right now that's
infectious, to say the least.
So how's the family's
doing over there?
VIELMA: They're great.
They're getting seated
and finding their water
on their seats, which we hope
will be a beautiful day today.
So they'll be needing that.
Can you please introduce
yourself, Allie,
to the families, guests, and
friends here in Killian Court?
[? POSHAY: ?] Sure.
My name is Allie
[? Poshay. ?] I'm a rising
junior in the Class of 2009.
And I'm majoring in Course
15, Management Science.
And I'm from Atlanta but
I'm living in New Bedford,
Massachusetts right now.
So I have a couple guests
I'd like to introduce.
They have some interesting
things on their black robes.
So guys, would you like
to say a few works?
OK, say your names.
And then, we'll go through and
talk about what you're wearing.
LUGO: I'm Valentina Lugo.
LOWRY: I'm David Lowry.
[? POULE: ?]
[INAUDIBLE] [? Poule. ?]
[? SUPPLE: ?]
Derek [? Supple. ?]
POSHAY: OK.
And what-- explain
what you're wearing.
LUGO: This is called a serape.
It represents that I've been a
member of [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
for four years here at MIT.
That's the Mexican-American
and Chicano organization,
although it's embracing
of all cultures.
And it's been like my
family while I've been here.
POSHAY: OK,
LOWRY: This is a eagle feather
given to me by my father-in-law
and braided by my wife.
The beads are burgundy
and silver to represent
MIT'S school colors.
And I'm Lumbee
Indian, and that's
why I have the eagle feather.
But the burgundy
beads symbolize seven,
which is the year
we're graduating, 2007.
POSHAY: Cool.
[? POULE: ?] Hey.
I'm wearing the
Tau Beta Pi sash.
It's the engineering
honor society.
It represents the top 10% of
graduating seniors on campus.
POSHAY: OK.
[? SUPPLE: ?] And I'm wearing
the green sustainability pledge
ribbon.
It's a pledge that
about 100 graduates
are taking to work to make
the companies they work for
and more environmentally
and socially responsible.
And it's a national pledge that
a couple of hundred colleges
are taking part in.
POSHAY: OK, wow.
Thank you, guys.
I appreciate you explaining
your interesting attire.
Back to you in
the court, Karina.
VIELMA: Thank you, Allie.
We have a great diversity
of students here at MIT.
So we'll check in
with Allie and get
some more of those
graduating seniors on camera.
What's next on
the program, Matt?
MCGANN: Well, commencement
marks the official end
of the academic year.
And although the pace changes
a bit during the summer,
the education continues
in many different forms
and for a varied
group of students,
as you'll see in the
next episode of ZigZag.
Let's check it out.
BOLTON: Coming to you from the
Wood Sailing Pavilion at MIT,
my name is Marsha Bolton,
And this is ZigZag.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Summer break is winding
down, and the class of 2010
will soon be arriving on campus.
But there's still plenty of
time to enjoy the New England
weather with a trip to the
beach or a sail on the Charles.
The summer is also a time
when MIT hosts students
from the local community
and from around the world
in pursuit of challenging
educational opportunities.
Building exotic
alternatively-fueled vehicles,
playing Quidditch
with underwater ROVs,
and doing
graduate-level research
as an undergrad are just some
of the answers you'll find here
to the age old question, what do
you do on your summer vacation?
For one international
group, the summer of 2006
provided an opportunity
to make a real difference
as they gathered at MIT
for the Vehicle Design
Summit, an event conceived
and organized by students.
BITELLO: The Vehicle
Design Summit
consists of students
from 13 countries,
about 20 universities.
ALLEN: We had four vehicle teams
that each designed and built
from scratch a complete vehicle
that carried either one or two
passengers and would really make
a positive impact on the issue
of commuter travel.
JAFFE: We're doing a ground-up
re-analysis of everything
you find in the car.
VAN HOEF: We're trying to build
a two-seater commuter car.
BOGGS: I really enjoy
designing things.
And this event is really
full of designing.
RITTER: This isn't--
it's not for fun.
It's not for a competition
that ends and we're done.
We are trying to do something
very real, very serious,
and have an impact in
the world right now.
ALLEN: One of cars we made, the
AHPV, Assisted Human Powered
Vehicle, so maybe if they're
part of the power source,
if they need to pedal in order
to move the car in addition
to having a battery pack
and an electric motor,
that was kind of the key tenant.
We also made a biofuels car.
And that team was
very interested in,
how do you run a car
on vegetable oil--
SVO or straight vegetable oil?
It has four wheels
and two passengers.
And they made a
steel space frame.
We also made a fuel
cell electric hybrid.
It's predominantly an electric--
three-wheeled electric
with two passengers.
And our other car
is called Pulse,
meaning it's supposed to
be the pulse of the city.
Kind of a commuter concept
that just has one person
and was just to
show, here's what--
if you're commuting
by yourself, here's
where your car might look
like if it was all electric.
[CHATTER]
The biggest
priorities of our work
are to get students
together and show
that really passionate
people can do a lot
and that an issue,
like global warming,
is really not ephemeral.
Even though it's in
many different realms
and many different
markets, there
are ways of chipping away
at it little by little.
BOLTON: If you've spent any
time around MIT this summer,
you've probably noticed crowds
of students a little younger
than your average undergrad.
They're participants in
the School of Engineering's
engineering outreach programs.
CARTER: The Office of
Engineering Outreach Programs
currently has three major
programs in the office.
The first and the
flagship program,
which has been
around the longest,
is the MIT Minority Introduction
To Engineering and Sciences,
or the MITES program.
Typically, we bring about
60 to 80 students to campus
from across the
country, and they
study what is a mini
freshmen experience
for about six weeks--
courses in life sciences,
engineering design,
internet programming,
genomics, calculus, physics,
and humanities.
The second program is SEED
Academy, Saturday Engineering
Enrichment and Discovery.
We keep the kids for
three and a half years.
And they basically spend
10 Saturdays a semester
with us doing hands-on
kinesthetic learning
in engineering disciplines.
And the third program,
which is the newest,
is the Science
Technology Engineering
and Mathematics program.
That's STEM.
That program is for
middle school students.
We enrich their middle
school experience
by teaching them
advanced topics, things
like algebraic topology,
descriptive geometry, physics,
probability and
statistics, and programming
in a five-week intensive
program during the summer.
PROFESSOR: Three, two, one.
[APPLAUSE]
ANGELA: The best part about
STEM was meeting new people
and learning about more
stuff, because it actually
stretched our brains.
CARTER: These programs
are important because A,
you get students
to come together
and see that there are other
students like them that
love to ask the same
probing questions
and have a fire, a passion
in the belly for science
and technology.
And two, it helps
us to teach students
to ask the why questions.
And that's what we need
more of in this country.
BOLTON: For some of this
year's MITES students,
the summer ended with a
splash, as they participated
in the first ever MITES
underwater Remotely Operated
Vehicle, or ROV competition.
STUDENT: This way.
This way.
Swim that way.
[CHEERING]
AMAYA: Today, we had
the kids show off
their five weeks of work.
And what they had to do was
build an underwater machine
called an ROV.
And we had them do three
types of competitions today.
They did a quick drag race,
a weightlifting competition,
and finally, we had a
Quidditch match underwater.
NAPIER: We won the competition.
We came in first place
overall based on the fact
that we performed highest in
all the three competitions.
But this is our beautiful
machine, Cardinal.
MORIARTY: In this
class, I'm trying
to have them ask the
questions, to have
them be the ones
observing something
and ask the questions about it.
So I'm really trying to get them
to be actively the ones driving
what we're doing, where they
can really just get involved,
get immersed in it.
CARTER: There's a
tradition here at MIT
that before any major challenge,
that students get dunked.
They get thrown into the moat
or the pool or the shower.
And I heard a rumor that
the winning team stepped up
to that challenge and threw the
teaching assistant in the pool.
I don't know if it's true--
true or not.
But if it is, very much in
line with the MIT tradition.
STUDENT: Go.
[SPLASH]
[LAUGHTER]
BOLTON: A couple
of episodes back,
we met the students from
MIT'S Summer Research Program,
or MSRP, as they were beginning
their nine-week stay on campus.
It's been an intense
couple of months
for these 57 undergraduates
from around the country.
They've taken on projects
and diverse topics,
such as robotics, nuclear
engineering, material science,
and design.
And their graduate-level
work has resulted
in seven likely publications.
But they've also
managed to enjoy trips
to Woods Hole in
Martha's Vineyard.
And at the final celebration,
they received a surprise visit
from Randal Pinkett, winner
of last season's Apprentice
and an MIT PhD.
PINKETT: Having been through MIT
and knowing the MSRP program,
first of all, let
me congratulate you.
It's a great time
to be involved.
for you finishing up.
So hopefully, you enjoy this.
Enjoy the day.
Celebrate your accomplishments.
And recharge your batteries
for the fall semester.
WILLIAMS: This program has
definitely changed my thoughts
about the future.
When I came in here,
I had a set path,
but now, things just kind of
got changed, but for the good,
for the better, definitely.
So I have more direction now.
BOLTON: It seems
certain that we'll
be hearing from these
outstanding students
again as they continue to pursue
careers and break new ground
in science and technology.
That's all for now.
For ZigZag, I'm Marsha Bolton.
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIELMA: As some of
these stories indicate,
MIT actively recruits students
from around the world.
And the ways in which
students discover MIT
is as varied as the
students themselves.
We recently asked a group
of graduating seniors
how and why they discovered MIT.
So let's take a look.
PEARCE: When I was really
small, I played with LEGOs
in my front window.
NEDZEL: I kept a listing of
all the different product
numbers in the LEGO
catalog that I wanted.
LUGO: Sometimes, I would create
math problems for myself.
GUERRA: I saw the
moving images on the TV,
but I couldn't explain
why that was happening.
So I started taking
the TV apart.
PEARCE: That was
my first experience
with working with my hands
and trying to build things.
And when I learned that that
was actually engineering,
MIT made all the
sense in the world.
NEDZEL: From my dad,
he definitely wanted
me to come here.
I said, I don't
want to go to MIT.
I don't want anything
to do with this place.
He sort of took a
step back and tried
to allow me to find my own
way, why this school was
such a wonderful place for me.
He just really drew out the
person I've always been,
and that person was someone
that was made to go to MIT.
PEARCE: My perception
of MIT was that it
was a cold, boring place.
HOPEMAN: I had heard about MIT.
It was a distance school,
great in engineering.
But I had never had any
real desire to come here.
NEDZEL: But when I got here,
I just found so much more.
LUGO: I met people from all
over the country and all
over the world.
SCHOR: I have friends on
the varsity pistol team that
went to Nationals this year.
I have friends who do ballroom
dance competitions or salsa
lessons.
Everyone has their own
thing and their own style.
And it really adds to the
personality and depth at MIT.
SLUTSKY: MIT is so intense,
so challenging, and yet,
so rewarding that I think
that the experience you
gain in four years is unlike
any throughout the country.
PEARCE: It became
abundantly clear to me
that MIT was really
a unique place,
and I saw the greatness of the
people who were around here.
And I figured I wanted
to be a part of that.
[AUDIO OUT]
MCGANN: We're back now.
Today, we have graduating
families celebrating
bachelor's degrees, master's
degrees, and doctoral degrees.
And here with me today, we've
pulled out of the crowd,
somewhat at random, the family
of a master's degree student.
So first of all,
let's introduce the--
can you introduce to us who
we're celebrating today?
TAYLOR: We're celebrating
my husband, Daniel Taylor.
And I'm his wife, Lauren.
TAYLOR: I'm his mother, Lynn.
TAYLOR: His father, Glen Taylor.
STOVALL: And I'm the
mother-in-law, Joanne Stovall.
MCGANN: And where are
you all up from today?
TAYLOR: Florida.
MCGANN: Florida.
And can you tell me a little
bit about your husband
and his experiences at MIT?
How has his experience?
TAYLOR: Oh, his experience
has been wonderful.
We initially came
here because he
wanted to go to a school
that would give him
so many opportunities.
And that's what it
really gave him.
So everything he did, he
loved, no matter how hard.
So it was great.
MCGANN: How was it
coming from Florida
to deal with these
New England winters?
What was that like for you guys?
TAYLOR: I hate snow.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER: So now, when
we were talking earlier,
you were telling me--
how did your husband get
to school every day?
TAYLOR: He rode his bike.
And then, when the
snow was too much,
he would just walk with boots.
MCGANN: So you had to outfit
yourselves for the winter,
go to the store, buy
a whole bunch of stuff
that you'd never
need in Florida?
TAYLOR: Yes.
The first winter we had
our spatulas and everything
scraping the windshields.
And then, we went and got
all the proper things,
so it was good.
MCGANN: So now that
he has graduated,
what will he do professionally?
What's he doing?
TAYLOR: Well, we already
moved back to Florida.
And he's working in a firm in
Orlando doing public works,
so we like it a lot.
MCGANN: And how has he used
his MIT knowledge in the firm
and out in the real world?
TAYLOR: Well, he's kind of
taken over all the computer
responsibilities at his new job.
And he's teaching everyone how
to do all these new programs
that are out, so.
MCGANN: So when
he was growing up,
did you ever imagine that
he would go off to MIT?
Was he the MIT type?
TAYLOR: Oh, yes, always.
From the time he
was two years old,
I knew that he would
be doing great things.
MCGANN: And you were
saying that he was also,
like in the video, one
of those students who
was taking apart things and--
TAYLOR: Always.
From the time he
was two years old,
his favorite toy was LEGOs.
He never wanted to go outside.
He just wanted to do things.
And twice when he was
in elementary school,
he won the state science
fair with different designs
that he had done with LEGOs.
MCGANN: Now, do you feel
that your daughter has
chosen a good man?
Are you very proud of
your son-in-law today?
STOVALL: I am extremely
proud of my son-in-law.
And also, not only did
he graduate from MIT,
but in this last year,
my daughter and he
had their first child.
So he did all of his
studies while they
were planning for
the baby, so he
was pretty dedicated and busy.
MCGANN: So maybe
your grandson will
be class of MIT, what, 2025?
STOVALL: Well, my
granddaughter--
MCGANN: Oops.
STOVALL: --will be
a graduate of 2025.
MCGANN: So you'll all be back
here in about 18, no 22 years,
something like that.
STOVALL: We plan to be, yes.
MCGANN: All right, great.
We're going to throw
it back over to Karina.
What's next?
[INAUDIBLE]
VIELMA: Well, we're
going to check back
in Johnson Athletic Center
to see what Allie's up to.
Allie, how are you
doing over there?
How are the graduates?
[? POSHAY: ?]
Pretty good, Karina.
It's filled up quite
a bit, actually.
There's a lot more hoods,
a lot more graduates
just standing around
eating breakfast.
So I have a couple more
to interview for you.
We have--
[? CHOW: ?] Elaine [? Chow. ?]
POSHAY: --and--
MARTINEZ: Josue Martinez.
[? POSHAY: ?] Okay,
and where are you from?
CHOW: I'm from Oklahoma City.
MARTINEZ: San Juan, Puerto Rico.
[? POSHAY: ?] Okay, so
you are a grad student?
CHOW: I am.
I'm in the MBA program.
[? POSHAY: ?] Oh, and
did you travel with that?
CHOW: I traveled a lot.
It was great.
[? POSHAY: ?] Where did you go?
CHOW: I went to Mexico.
I went to Costa Rica.
I went to Vietnam, Israel,
bunch of different places--
Montreal, if that counts.
POSHAY: Wow, okay.
One more.
So what did you do at MIT?
MARTINEZ: From study, built a
lot of stuff with my friends,
just hung out,
played video games.
[? POSHAY: ?] So
you had a good time?
That's what you--
you build stuff?
MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Oh, build stuff--
bars, cars, just
a little bit of everything.
[? POSHAY: ?] Okay, all right.
So you build anything
in particular
that was your
favorite thing, you
were just really proud of it?
MARTINEZ: Oh, my favorite
thing of all time--
last year, I built a
full-size loft and bar.
Took me like a week to
build, polished, urethaned,
everything.
It's amazing.
It's a gem.
[? POSHAY: ?] It got put to use?
MARTINEZ: It got
put to use for sure.
But don't tell the
administration.
[? POSHAY: ?]
[LAUGHS] All right.
Back to you, Karina,
in the court.
VIELMA: Thank you, Allie.
As these students
have demonstrated,
MIT students achieve
in a variety of ways--
clearly in the classroom and
in laboratories, but also,
they achieve in the playing
fields and the concert--
in the concert hall.
The arts at MIT
play a vital role
in the overall
educational experience,
as this next video illustrates.
BRODY: One morning, I came
up the steps of Massachusetts
Avenue and walked
through the door,
and the entire space had been
transformed into a wheat field.
Innovative visual arts projects
like that are happening
all the time on campus.
The arts at MIT, like science
and engineering at MIT,
are on the cutting edge
of their disciplines.
They are serving the students.
STUDENT: And I've got a
rap sheet that's got a--
BRODY: And in the way
they're serving the students,
ultimately, they're going to
be serving the entire society.
[VIOLIN MUSIC]
TSENG: At MIT, you'll find
some of the best musicians,
virtuosos, completely.
The person who lives next
door to me has perfect pitch.
And if you name any
song whatsoever,
he can strum it
out on his guitar.
If it has multiple
lines of music,
he can strum out all
the lines on his guitar.
And you can see that.
It's indicative of the level
of quality at the MIT symphony
orchestra, the MIT
concert choir, et cetera.
TSIEN: Last year, I got to
premiere a song cycle written
by an MIT composer, and
that was a lot of fun--
modern poetry, modern
music, and everything.
STUDENT: Everyone at MIT
cares about something,
whether it's their classes
or their [INAUDIBLE]
or some student
activity they do.
There's always something
that they really care about.
SONENBERG: The thing
about MIT students
that I most appreciate
is the elegance
of their thinking and the fact
that it's sort of live and let
live here.
CHOIR: (SINGING) [INAUDIBLE]
Ooh wah wah wah wah.
[INDIAN MUSIC PLAYING]
SONENBERG: There's a
point of concentration
that any discipline requires,
whether it's engineering,
or it's directed or
acting or painting.
That point concentration
is the focal point.
It is the thing around which
you organize your thinking
and your technique.
And so the fact that there
is ensemble work where people
learn to work
collaboratively is something
that I see that people take
into their laps in a way
that you would hope that labs
would work collaboratively.
[MUSIC PLAYING - SANTANA FT. ROB
THOMAS, "SMOOTH"]
(SINGING) Because
you're so smooth.
And it's just like the
ocean under the moon.
It's the same as the
emotion that I get from you.
You've got the kind of loving
that can be so smooth, yeah.
Give me your heart.
Make it real, or
else, forget about it.
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: I'll kill you all.
STUDENT: He kills me.
Ooh.
Ahh.
[LAUGHTER]
SARWATE: Well, right now,
it's sort of-- the theater
is a way I can investigate
my own sort of identity,
especially my own
cultural identity.
But I'm also-- enjoy
theater because it's so--
such a collaborative art.
And it's a lot like engineering,
which is one of my majors.
And I also intend to
pursue engineering,
and that is so collaborative.
And so you get a lot of
different people's perspective
on things.
[CHATTER]
ARNING: I'm Bill Arning.
I'm the curator at the MIT
List Visual Art Center.
And I'm here in our annual
student loan exhibition.
MIT, quite unusually,
has a collection
of artworks that students
get to live with for a year.
D'ARBELOFF: Arts are in
every new building now.
It's pervasive from
that point of view.
And it's pervasive
from the things
that you see people
doing all over.
My favorite program is
the Council Scholars,
of course, because I'm
very involved with them.
It started with 20 or so
undergraduate students.
And now, we have both
undergraduate and graduate
students--
computer scientists.
There are chemical engineers.
There are
architectural students.
And they are not,
with a few exceptions,
actually going out and leading
professional lives as artists.
But this is something that's
been very important to them
all their lives.
THOMPSON: We find our students,
a certain number of them,
go on to graduate study
in music and in the arts.
Some of them go on to become
leaders of arts organizations
within their communities.
Some of them go on to
sing in organizations,
in performing organizations,
like the Tanglewood Festival
Chorus.
And in a couple of
notable situations,
I have myself, a
number of times,
been engaged by organizations
whose presidents
were either in my class
at MIT 20 years ago
or had been at MIT
years before that.
[CLASSICAL MUSIC]
My first visit to MIT--
when I walked
through the halls, I
remember passing through
the math department
on the way to Building
14, where we used to be.
And I looked in a door
and saw mathematicians
hunched in [INAUDIBLE].
And I felt right at home.
Because that looked
exactly like walking down
the halls at Julliard
into the practice rooms
and seeing people working
personally on something.
[? LOCKHART: ?] One of the
amazing things about MIT
students is the incredible
wide range of interests
and abilities that extend
far beyond the intellectual
and the academic.
And our special guest with us
this section of the concert
is no exception to that.
His name is Jonathan Lee.
[APPLAUSE]
[SYMPHONY MUSIC]
GOEL: I think that
being involved
in activities like this only
enhances your education.
I think it's important
that while you're
at school to focus on things
besides your own research.
SONENBERG: So people come here
as scientists, as engineers,
as mathematicians.
But when they are making
art, they're artists.
[DRUMMING]
STUDENT: (CHANTING) People
moving out, people moving in.
Why?
Because of the
color of their skin.
[INAUDIBLE]
D'ARBELOFF: I think it's
a way of chilling out
some of the stresses you have.
It's a way of looking at the
things you're doing in a--
with a broader picture.
TSIEN: It's like
anything you want to do,
MIT students will go off
and form a group for it.
And then, they'll
actually carry it through.
Because they put all
their engineering skills
to work, and they
engineer these art groups.
And there are piles of them.
STUDENT: Hi, we're
The Corollaries.
We have our new CD,
which you should by.
We're the Institute's only
co-ed, secular, all-MIT,
non-jazz competing
a capella group.
So that makes this special.
And you're all special too.
We're going to sing
another song now.
THE COROLLARIES: (SINGING)
We are the engineers.
Yes, we are the engineers.
TSIEN: So you shouldn't
think that MIT
has no art, because
they've got them
sprawling all over the place.
BRODY: Well, now, the advice
I give to incoming freshmen
consistently is don't
leave your trumpet at home.
You can use it here.
MCGANN: So we've
got a live check-in
over at Johnson Athletic Center,
where the graduates are busily
getting ready for
their walk over here.
So can you see?
Can you find your
graduate out there?
Right now, while MIT students
are, in the long-term, focused
on that mission of MIT
to change the world,
to make the world a
better place, right now,
their mission, I think, is
just to get in that snack line,
grab some muffins
and orange juice.
Now, you should know
that at MIT, there are--
there are no classes that
really begin before 10:00 AM.
So this is extremely
early for MIT students.
So you can see a lot of
sleepy students in line.
But they're very excited to
be walking up that main aisle
and sitting in these
black seats in front of us
not very long from now.
So right now, what
we're going to do
is-- we just saw in a video
about the arts at MIT.
Now, we're going to throw
it to a ZigZag piece looking
at other activities at MIT.
MIT has just a
plethora of activities,
more than 330 different student
groups, 41 varsity sports.
There's so much to do.
Why don't you check
this piece out?
It's really quite interesting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Coming to you from the Johnson
Athletic Center at MIT,
My name is Matt McGann.
And this is ZigZag, now
available in high-definition.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
At most campuses
across the country,
athletics are an integral part
of the college experience.
At MIT, students apply
the same passion, drive,
and commitment to athletics
as they do academics.
The Institute fields
41 NCAA teams,
as many as any other
school in the nation.
But when it comes to athletics,
the key word is participation.
More than 10,000 members
of the MIT community
participate every year in a rich
and varied intramural program.
At MIT, students would
rather be on the field
than in the stands.
ANDERSON: One of
the reasons I really
enjoy working here at MIT is
because our student athletes
don't have to sacrifice
their academics for athletics
and vice-versa.
We want our student
athletes here
to do just what that term says.
You're a student first,
and you're an athlete next.
On an annual basis,
we get 760,000 visits
in our recreation department.
And our varsity sports, I
think that speaks for itself.
We have 41 varsity sports.
And we're tied with
Harvard for the most
sports at any institution
of higher learning.
The breadth and depth of our
program is an inclusive one.
We have 29 clubs.
We have a strong
intramural sports program.
You take a PE class, for
instance, our students may come
here and never skated before.
They put on a pair of skates.
And they learn to skate.
And two months later, they're
playing in an ice hockey game.
That's just unreal to me.
But the MIT students, they want
to be excellent at everything
they do.
So it doesn't surprise me
at all to see that happen.
And it happens on
a regular basis.
Our student athletes, when we
get a chance to work with them,
they learn leadership.
They learn to work as a team.
They learn that they can push
themselves beyond whatever
thought they could do.
They learn to take charge
without taking over.
And these are the
same kind of skills
that you can take
from the playing field
and get to the boardroom,
and you can use those there.
We know that they are
really, really prepared
when they move to the next
game, which is the game of life.
MCGANN: MIT fields more than
2,000 intramural sports teams
and nearly two dozen sports.
And 80% of MIT students
participate in some form
of organized athletics.
We all know that MIT is renowned
for academic excellence.
It's known as the leader
in science and technology.
But it's also known
for mariachi bands?
That's what the freshman
class discovered at the 2006
Activities Midway, where
they were introduced
to the wide, wide world
of clubs and organizations
available to students at MIT.
ENDERTON: We are
the MIT Energy Club.
And what we do is we
try and bring together
the business, technology, and
policy communities at MIT.
CHU: I'm with Dance Troupe.
And basically, we're the largest
dance organization at MIT.
ANDREWS: The MIT
Marching Band goes out
to football games and
other sporting events,
and helps keep the pep going.
RUSH: Course 16.5,
Aero-Disastro,
which is the MIT
student juggling club.
And I should be able
to juggle five balls
while talking on the
microphone, hitting
Matt McGann, in the head.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHANDAWARKAR: I'm in
The Corollaries of MIT.
We're the oldest coed a
capella group on campus.
DENIS: The MIT
Ballroom Dance Team
gives me another outlet for
my energies and emotions.
MONZON: Our group is called MIT
Filipino Students Association.
It helped me a lot
in making new friends
and basically just
promoting the culture.
BUCHWALD: We are the
cheer squad at MIT.
And we cheer for football
and basketball games.
CHEERLEADERS: E to the U. U
to the X. E to the x to the x.
Cosine, secant, tangent, sine.
3.14159.
Integral, radical,
[INAUDIBLE] MIT.
STEIN: Our group is the
Laboratory for Chocolate
Sciences, and we do
anything you could
want to do with chocolate.
O'REILLY: We'd build and operate
a HO-scale model railroad.
And we build all the electronics
and write all the software.
And we can actually run
the layout remotely.
DARBE: Design For a
Change is involved
in international
development work.
It's a real and
meaningful impact.
HASTINGS: If a
student is not doing
these kinds of
activities, then they're
going to be a one-dimensional
kind of person.
But we're in the business of
creating holistic students.
SHAHIR: MIT students
who I've noticed so far
are very passionate
about what they do here.
RIVAS JR: I've made
many, many friends here
and really have enjoyed--
great-- I know they're going
to be lifelong friendships.
[MARIACHI MUSIC]
PRESENTER: The start
of the new semester
also saw the observance
of another MIT
tradition, the hack.
Regular viewers of ZigZag will
remember our coverage of a hack
last semester, in which the
Cal Tech cannon appeared
mysteriously on MIT'S campus.
This term, the fifth
anniversary of September 11,
was commemorated by the
equally mysterious appearance
of a full-sized fire truck
perched atop MIT'S Great Dome.
CHANDAWARKAR: I saw the
fire engine on the Dome
when I was walking over
the bridge in the morning.
And me and my friends
were like, oh,
that must be a commemoration
for September 11.
HAREL: We got here on Sunday.
It was our first
tour of the campus.
And well, it was
a nice surprise,
even for our tour guide.
He showed us and explained
the whole hacking culture.
LAM: I'm not surprised
that MIT did a fire
engine on top of the Dome.
MIT has a lot of respect and
a lot of caring for issues.
DERSH: I thought it
was very well done.
I know the police
car back in the day
got a lot of media
and everything.
So it's something that
people always remember.
And this one had
even more meaning.
HAREL: I think it's
really a nice gesture.
CHANDAWARKAR: We have no
idea across the river how
they do it.
But it provides lots of
people entertainment.
DERSH: I think it's
a good thing to have.
MCGANN: That's all for now.
For ZigZag, I'm Matt McGann.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, we're back here.
And Karina has found another
very nice looking MIT family
from the audience.
So Karina, who do we have here?
VIELMA: Well, Matt, I'm
here with the Vielma family.
They're going to see
their daughter graduate.
Is that correct?
VIELMA: Yeah, that's correct.
VIELMA: What is her name?
VIELMA: Her name
is Lucia Vielma.
VIELMA: Lucia.
And you are-- can you
please each tell me just
how you're related to her?
VIELMA: She's my daughter.
VIELMA: Mom.
VIELMA: Brother.
VIELMA: Her older brother.
VIELMA: Sister.
VIELMA: Great.
Isn't this a beautiful
looking family?
Is this the first time that
you come to commencement?
VIELMA: No, this is the second
one-- the first one that we got
interviewed.
But it's the second one
that we are on this place.
VIELMA: And what
was the first time
that you came for commencement?
VIELMA: The first time
was when you graduated.
VIELMA: Oh, that's right.
They were here
for my graduation.
This is my family, folks.
Thank you for being such great
families and coming up here.
But I wanted to ask you
about my sister, Lucia,
who's graduating.
Did she behave in any
way like the MIT types?
VIELMA: No.
I never thought that she
was going to come here.
Because when she was younger,
she was a little lazier
than you are.
So I thought that
she was not coming,
because I know that anybody
coming to this place
have to work very
hard to make it.
And I thought that she was
not going to come here.
VIELMA: Well, she did.
How did you guys see
your sister, Lucia?
VIELMA: She was the smart one.
VIELMA: Smarter than me?
VIELMA: Um.
VIELMA: OK, OK,
don't answer that.
[LAUGHTER]
Does she do anything
besides the--
over ordinary, extraordinary?
VIELMA: I'm not sure.
[LAUGHTER]
VIELMA: How about you, Frank?
VIELMA: Well, you
know, I'm an Aggie.
So it's pretty cool
to be an Aggie.
But I wish I was a little
bit more like my sisters.
I mean, when I was a senior,
my younger sister Lucia,
was a freshman.
And we were in a
academic competition.
And she actually beat
me in that competition--
me being the senior, and
her being the freshman--
which I thought was pretty
amazing thing she did.
VIELMA: Wow, that's amazing.
So as a freshman, she
beat you in a competition.
Great.
That's the MIT type.
How about you, Irene?
Are you coming to MIT?
VIELMA: I don't know.
VIELMA: Do you like
math and science?
VIELMA: Yes.
VIELMA: Are you considering MIT?
VIELMA: What do you mean?
VIELMA: OK, I guess she hasn't
started thinking about that.
So is there any
message that you want
to give to the
graduating class today?
VIELMA: Well, congratulations
in your graduation.
I think that you all
work hard down here,
and you deserve the best on
your professional careers.
VIELMA: Thank you very much.
This is the Vielma
family, folks.
Matt, now back to you.
MCGANN: Looks like we
in the admissions office
are going to have to look
out for an application,
maybe, from Irene.
We'll look out for that.
Irene Vielma-- remember that
back in the admissions office.
So right now what
we're going to do
is we're going to kick it
back over to Allie at Johnson.
She's got some more
graduates who she'll talk to.
So who do you have, Allie?
[? POLSHOY: ?] Hi, Matt.
We have two doctorate
students and an undergraduate.
And they have some pretty
interesting headwear.
And I just wanted to ask
them a little bit about it.
So what are your names?
Where are you from?
ELIZABETH: My name is Elizabeth,
and I'm from Honolulu, Hawaii.
FITZMORRIS: I'm Jean Fitzmorris.
I'm from Massachusetts.
ZOS: I'm [? Zos, ?] and I'm
from Adelaide, South Australia.
POLSHOY: South Australia, okay.
So what are you
wearing on your head?
ELIZABETH: I'm
wearing a Haku lei.
It's a type of Hawaiian lei
that's traditionally worn,
I guess, during graduation.
It's kind of a celebration.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Okay.
FITZMORRIS: This is the
Green Monster, Fenway Park.
And it's complete with Manny
Ramirez at the outfield wall.
My friends helped
me pu it together.
See it?
[? POLSHOY: ?] [LAUGHS]
It's very nice.
And what do you have
on your head, sir?
[? ZOS: ?] This
little guy is a robot.
He's a humanoid KHR1 robot.
And that's because I'm from the
robotic life group at the Media
Lab, and we never go
anywhere without our robots.
POLSHOY: Oh.
Oh.
I see that.
So he's going to wave
at your graduation?
ZOS: Right.
Right.
It's partly his graduation too.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Oh, so you
built it last night or--
[? ZOS: ?] Well, I
rigged up everything
and did some
software last night.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Okay,
just overnight.
[? ZOS: ?] Yeah.
No sleep for the wicked.
[? POLSHOY: ?] No sleep.
OK.
So he doesn't sleep
before his graduations.
[LAUGHS] Do you guys
have anything you
want to say to the families?
ELIZABETH: Hi, Mom and
Dad, and my sister.
FITZMORRIS:
Congratulations, everyone.
Thanks.
[? ZOS: ?] Definitely a
shout-out to Rosie and Simon.
Thanks for making the trip.
[? POLSHOY: ?] All right.
Let's take it back to
you guys in the court.
MCGANN: OK.
I wish that I had come up
with something really cool
to put on my headwear
when I graduated.
So keep an eye out for
that really cool headwear
as they walk down that aisle
not very long from now.
It's getting to be that time.
Well, our video
magazine, ZigZag,
is just one example of the rich
assortment of video content
that's available on the web.
The explosive
popularity of YouTube
demonstrates that
people not only
want to watch video
of their choosing
but also to create and
share their own content.
MIT recently launched its
own version of YouTube,
which is called MIT Tech TV.
This site will allow for the MIT
community, including students,
faculty, and staff,
to upload, view,
and share quality
science, engineering,
and MIT-related content,
providing a global audience
with a window into MIT.
It will not surprise you to
know that many of our students
are also talented media
producers, as evidenced
by these two pieces submitted
to the student video
contest sponsored by the Dean
of the School of Engineering.
Let's check it out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIELMA: Our very own MIT
President, Susan Hockfield,
has made the search for clean,
affordable, and sustainable
energy sources a top
priority here at MIT.
Here's a brief look at
just two initiatives--
of just two of the many
energy-related research
initiatives going
on around campus.
Let's take a look.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BOLTON: Across America, the
holiday season means travel.
In fact, the winter
holidays are traditionally
the busiest travel
times of the year.
On a typical holiday
weekend, the number
of long distance trips
increases by more than 50%.
And the vast majority of those
trips are made by automobile.
With soaring gasoline prices and
the threat of global warming,
addressing the global
energy challenge
HAS become a top
priority at MIT.
Hydrogen fuel cells, solar
power, and exotic battery
technology may all have a role
to play in our transportation
future.
But there are also
more immediate steps
that can be taken to improve the
efficiency of current gasoline
engines.
HEYWOOD: I've been working on
engines and then their fuel
requirements, because the
two are intimately connected,
for almost all of my
professional life.
Our idea of a half-size engine
is the best idea that I think I
and my co-inventors
collectively have come up with.
BROMBERG: We have been
driving these sort
of vehicles for 100 years.
And here, we can still
come up with something
that seems to be relatively
innovative, interesting
to explore.
COHN: John Heywood,
Leslie Bromberg, and I
have been working for some
time on bi-fueled gasoline
engines, that is
engines with two fuels,
as a way to improve
efficiency at low cost.
And these thoughts
just came together,
as is often the case when
you come up with a new idea,
in the thought that we could
use a small amount of ethanol
to really improve the
performance of spark ignition
gasoline engine.
The liquid ethanol is squirted
directly into the cylinder.
And there, it vaporizes.
And it has a tremendous
cooling effect.
This prevents engine knock.
Engine knock, which is
the unwanted detonation,
of the fuel has been a
major limitation on engine
performance and efficiency.
When the pressure and
temperature in the cylinder
get too high, the engine knocks.
And that can be damaging.
HEYWOOD: The gain in efficiency
relative to today's engines
is about 25%.
Our team is not motivated
by we want this to work
and so we'll make
a lot of money.
We want it to work so that
we have a substantive impact
on this big problem.
We're just using too much
energy, too much petroleum.
We're emitting too
much greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere.
We're 5% of the
world's population,
and we're using 25% of
the world's petroleum.
But there's a number
that I got recently
that's worse than that.
We're using 40% of
the world's gasoline.
Now, I think that's
a horrifying number.
So there's a compelling need to
reduce our energy consumption
in transportation, to reduce
our gasoline consumption.
So a better vehicle
helps everybody.
And we think this is real.
And it looks practical.
So it's got real potential
for having an impact.
BOLTON: The half-size
ethanol-boosted gasoline engine
may be showing up in production
vehicles within five years.
You can read more about energy
research initiatives at MIT
in the current issue of Spectrum
at web.mit.edu/giving/spectrum.
Is there an electric
car in your future?
One of the main
technological challenges
to the widespread use
of electric vehicles
is limited battery life.
But at MIT'S Laboratory for
Electromagnetic and Electronic
Systems, new research is
promising a viable alternative
to conventional batteries,
the ultra capacitor.
SCHINDALL: Research is
fascinating in that you often
end up doing something you
never expected to be doing.
We start with the
basic capacitor.
They're very, very
effective in that you
can charge and discharge
them indefinitely.
They store energy
just like a battery.
But they store much less energy
than a battery does, not enough
to be useful in
electronic devices.
Now, an ultra capacitor
is a great improvement
over an ordinary capacitor.
An ultra capacitor has about
1/25 the energy of a battery.
We were simply looking
at ultra capacitors
to see if they would be useful
to automobile manufacturers.
And we made the
connection that perhaps we
could take an old
product, a capacitor,
and make that old
product in a new way,
use a new technology,
nanotechnology,
or a nanotube technology,
and actually build
a product that is
better than what's
out there before at a
cost-effective price.
What we're doing is
taking a capacitor
and coating the plates
of the capacitor
with hair-like
nanotubes growing out
from the surface of
the capacitor plates.
The ions, which store
the electrical charge,
are attracted into the
spaces between the nanotubes,
allowing the capacitor to store
an amount of energy that's
comparable to what is
ordinarily stored by a battery.
That would be a
significant improvement
with many, many applications,
ranging from small devices that
could be more quickly
recharged to larger devices,
such as automobiles, where the
braking energy can be captured
in one of these devices.
And that braking energy can then
be used to accelerate the car
and make the overall
operation of the automobile
much, much more efficient.
BOLTON: That's all for now.
For ZigZag, I'm Marsha Bolton.
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MCGANN: Hello.
And we're back live
on Killian Court.
Earlier this week over
email, we sent out an email
to the entire graduating
student body and said,
would you like to have a
nice message read aloud
to the family and
friends watching here
live in Killian Court,
live on the web,
and also who will
buy the DVD at home?
And they responded in droves
with lots of really, really
nice messages.
And we wanted to read
some of them here.
We'll also read
a few for the web
audience at home
during the procession.
So the first one was from Karen
Condon, a graduating student
today.
And Karen writes,
"Grandma and Grandpa
Ebersole, thank you
so much for coming
to watch me graduate on your
50th wedding anniversary
and for the love and
support you've given to me
these past four years.
Happy anniversary.
Love, Karen."
I thought that was really sweet.
Heather Pressler writes, "Thank
you to my family, friends,
and mentors for all of your
support over the years,
especially Mom, Dad, Uncle
Ron, and Aunt Collette
for coming to my graduation;
my Alpha Phi sorority
sisters for great times at MIT;
and finally, Dr. Langer and Dr.
[? Whitrop, ?] professors
here at MIT, for helping
me develop as a researcher."
Thank you, Heather.
William [? Supply, ?] who will
get his degree in material
science and engineering today,
writes, "Dr. Matthew Handler,
you've been an inspiration to
me as a material scientist.
Thank you for your
confidence and mentorship
in my formative
years as a scientist.
I will miss you dearly."
Matt Pappy writes, "To my
grandparents, hi, and thanks
for coming to watch.
To my whole family,
thanks for your support."
This is a greeting
from [INAUDIBLE]
from Elmwood Park, New Jersey.
He says, "I'd like to thank my
mom, my dad, my brother, Saul,
and my girlfriend, Kayla,
for all of their support
and help getting me through
these past four years.
I know I'll be moving
far away, but everyone
will be close at heart."
Sun Mi Yu writes, "To my
grandfather, who did not
make it to see my
graduation but I
know is here in spirit, thanks
for always believing in me.
I made it.
Also, to my dear
aunt in Korea who
could not make it because
she's in chemotherapy,
this one is for you."
Silvana Arevalo
says, "To my family,
thank you for your
continued love
and support over the years.
You've been my
inspiration for achieving
what I have done today."
Rose [? Li ?] writes, "To mom
and dad, thank you for all
of your love and support.
I could never have
gotten to where
I am today without your
encouragement and faith."
Kelsey Byers writes, to "Aunt
Robin, Uncle Bob, Aunt Polly,
and Uncle Garrett, thank
you so much for the love
and support you've given me.
I love you all."
David Rush writes,
"Thanks, Mom and Dad,
for your love and
support and for letting
me make my own
decisions but always
being ready to offer
advice when I asked."
Kaitlyn [? Gianavanuchi ?]
says, "To Mom
and Dad, Bobbie and Danny, thank
you so much for being my rock
and for always inspiring me.
I love you more
than words can say."
Jenn Fish says, "To my
Fishes, Mom, Dad, and Chris,
I love you and could not
have done this without you."
Shirley Fung writes,
"Thanks to my family
for being supportive and
loving over the years,
always having my back.
And thanks to Andrew
for keeping me sane
and always bringing a smile
to my face when I am down."
Taylor Roan, who's
receiving degrees today
in mechanical
engineering and physics,
writes, "May thanks
to my angelic wife,
Kayna, who is too lovely
and kind to be terrestrial.
Your generous support
has been crucial.
I look forward to spending
the rest of eternity with you
and our little one
due this autumn."
Christina Glaser writes, "Big
up to Mom, Dad, and Bill."
Cynthia Walker, who will be
receiving her degree today
in mechanical
engineering, writes,
"To my family and fiance, thank
you for all of your support.
Without you, I would
never have made it.
Love you."
Moira [? Rassich ?] says,
"To my [? Rassich ?] family
and my whole Northport
family, thank you
for all of your
love and support.
I love you all."
Maurice [? Obaid ?]
says, "To my family--
my mother, [? Zalpha; ?] my
father, Khalil; and my sisters,
Nadine, Saraya, and Tatiana--
thank you for all of your
support and encouragement
through the years.
Thank you for believing in
me and standing behind me
in all of my endeavors.
I should hope that
I keep you proud.
Your Lebanese son, Maurice."
Chris Watson writes, "To mom
and dad and to my abuelita
and to Grandma and
Grandpa, also to everyone
who has supported me
over the years who
believed that I could do it."
Dwight Chambers
writes, "Many thanks
to my parents, who so
generously supported
me through a four-year
roller coaster.
Thanks to my brother who
constantly teaches me
about perspective."
And finally, Alice Zo, who
will be graduating today
with a degree in material
science and engineering,
says, "To my family, thank you
for convincing me to go to MIT
and for your continuing
support behind every decision
I have ever made.
To my friends,
even though we have
memories we'll never
remember, you guys
are some of the people
I'll never forget.
Love always, Alice."
Karina?
VIELMA: Well, Matt, as you know,
students who graduate from MIT
go just about everywhere.
Isn't that correct?
MCGANN: Well, some
of us stay here.
VIELMA: That's right.
You and I came back to MIT.
Well, in this next
video, we also
asked a selection of students
to share their thoughts
about what this day, graduation
commencement, means to them,
and where they go from here.
PEARCE: Using my MIT
chemical engineering degree,
I'm going to enter into a
doctoral program studying
management and organizations
at Northwestern University.
GARCIA: I'll be attending
UCLA in the aerospace division
working on structures to
get my master's degree.
SCHOR: In August, I'll
be leaving for Spain,
and I'm working for a
chemical engineering company.
So I essentially get to live in
Spain for nine months for free.
NEDZEL: I don't
know exactly where
I'm going to end up five
or 10 years down the road.
But I do know that it's going
to be some sort of role that
has interesting and
challenging problems that
need to be solved.
And it will be a role
that, in some way,
can positively
influence society.
PEARCE: This is a place
where people are committed
to changing the world.
And so we students come
here, and we get educated.
We come up with new ideas.
And then, we go back
into the communities
from whence we came AND start
solving the problems that we
see exist, using the skills
that we developed here at MIT.
LUGO: When I get my
diploma on Friday,
my mom is probably going to be
crying and, at the same time,
shouting out, that's my kid,
and just excited knowing--
and proud knowing that
not only I did this,
but she helped me do this.
SLUTSKY: So it will be more
than just me being ecstatic.
It'll be them
knowing that they've
put a child through MIT.
And they claim that they deserve
honorary degrees as well.
HOPEMAN: Oh, they're
going to be so proud.
My parents are so
proud that I'm here.
PEARCE: I recognize that the
common thread of my experience
is that I could do more
than I ever thought I could.
My brain has been able
to hold more information
than I ever thought it could.
And as I approached this
time to get my degree
and look back on what
an MIT degree will mean,
it will mean the end
of a long journey.
It will mean the beginning
of a lifetime of leadership
and change for society.
MCGANN: All right, so we're
going to go back to Allie one
last time here.
There's a lot of excitement,
and she has one last interview
that we've got to
learn a little bit more
about what's going
on over there.
So Allie, what's
going on right now?
[? POLSHOY: ?] Hi, Matt.
We have.
Ms. Julie Norman
with us right now,
who's going to give us
a little lowdown on how
this whole thing happens.
So, Ms. Norman, I
understand that this takes
a lot of logistical prep work.
And it's done a
little differently
than some other colleges do it.
Can you explain
that a little bit?
NORMAN: Well, the
logistical part
is that we line the
students up in order,
march them in four
columns to Killian,
and when they cross
the stage, we give them
their own personal diploma.
And so to make that happen
with about 2,500 graduates
is rather challenging.
But we can do.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Wow.
Wow, that's incredible.
Everybody gets
their own diploma.
NORMAN: That's correct.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Wow.
How many people are
graduating right now?
NORMAN: We have about
2,300 students today, just
under 2,300.
[? POLSHOY: ?] So
is everybody here?
NORMAN: We hope so.
[? POLSHOY: ?] We hope so.
So how do you manage to
get from here all the way
over to Killian and
everybody's makes it okay?
How does that work?
NORMAN: Well, we will process
in just a few moments.
In just a few minutes,
we'll be leaving.
And we will process
out of this building
and down Amherst Alley towards
Killian Court, where we meet up
with the rest of the stage
party and follow them in.
So as you can see, the students
are getting a little anxious.
It's warm here.
And we're getting ready to go.
We do need to exit this
building and get them outside.
And they're excited.
This is a bed of high
energy and anticipation.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Yeah, I
could certainly feel it.
It seems like the happiest
place on the planet right now.
And you can tell everybody's
a little anxious.
We have a couple people
running through here.
So how was the--
how long have you
been awake today?
Did you go to sleep last
night in preparation?
NORMAN: Oh, absolutely,
for about four hours.
[LAUGHTER]
[? POLSHOY: ?] So how
long have you been here?
NORMAN: Since 6:00 this morning.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Oh, wow.
I woke up at 6:00 this morning.
NORMAN: This
happens once a year.
And this is why we're all here.
It's the most exciting day
on the campus each year.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Right.
Can I ask you a little bit--
what colors are you wearing?
NORMAN: I am a graduate--
did my graduate work
at the University of Texas,
and I am a toxicologist
and industrial hygienist.
So this is health and science.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Why MIT?
NORMAN: I came here--
I was at Montana Tech
as a faculty member.
I came to MIT in 2000, and
I'm a senior associate dean
for undergraduate education.
[? POLSHOY: ?] So you're the
head lady in here right now?
NORMAN: Yes.
[? POLSHOY: ?] Okay,
well, thank you very much.
I won't keep you any longer.
NORMAN: You're very welcome.
I'll see everyone in the Court.
[? POLSHOY: ?] All
right, back to you, Matt.
MCGANN: OK, as we just heard
from Dean Julie Norman,
it really is an amazing feat to
have those 2,200-plus graduates
get their actual diploma.
And I remember, when I walked
across that stage right up
there and received my degree--
actually from Charles Vest,
who's today's
commencement speaker--
it was an amazing
feeling to open it
up and see my actual MIT diploma
as I descended down the ramp.
And that was when I
knew that I made it.
And that will be
an amazing feeling
that your students will have
in just a few hours from now.
So we're getting ready for
those columns to come on over.
But before we do that,
I do have to make
some important announcements.
So let me do that now.
So I know that
each of you here is
going to be very
anxious to get the best
possible view or photograph
of your graduate,
as my parents were.
But I urge you to
remain respectful
of your fellow guests
while doing so.
Please do not stand on
chairs while taking pictures.
We honestly-- seriously
here-- have had folks
get hurt doing this.
And it's also quite
disrespectful and rude
to those folks who
are behind you.
So don't stand on the chairs.
And be respectful as
you're taking your pictures
of your graduates.
I would ask you that as the
ceremonies begin or perhaps
now as you're thinking of it,
put your cell phones and pagers
on silent or vibrate mode so as
to not disrupt the ceremonies.
Don't call your graduate
as they're processing in.
Graduates really do need
to maintain line of march,
and this can be distracting.
The medical tent is located
at the rear of Killian Court.
That big white tent will be
where you can get medical help
if you need it.
So that's where you'll
find the medical tent.
You also see student
EMTs wandering around.
And I think that's
really neat that we
do have student EMTs on campus
that are available to help.
And if you need that, just yell
or go back to the medical tent.
Official photographs and DVDs
may be ordered of the ceremony
today.
Ordering info is that
the info tents here
in the court, located in
both of the lower courts.
You can also order the
DVD and the photographs
on the official
commencement website
when you get home if you like.
Concessions are available
in the lower courts.
Coffee, tea,
beverages, and snacks
are available for
purchase if you so like.
Water bottles-- you found
them for free on your chairs.
And please do keep
yourself hydrated.
Today will get up
to about 77 degrees.
So keep yourself hydrated.
If you need more water,
there is more water
available at the info
tents in the lower courts.
Restroom facilities--
very important,
people are always looking
for the restroom facilities.
They are located in
the lower rear court.
You can see them
in the teal color.
So look for them.
If you need any help today
with restrooms, water, medical,
the folks in the red jackets--
not the class of 1957; that's
a different red jacket--
but the volunteer red jacket,
you can grab any of them.
They're extremely helpful and
can help you with anything
you need today.
And finally, I should
note that in the program
that you picked
up as you walk in,
the words to the
National Anthem and also
to the MIT school song in praise
of MIT are printed in there.
So if you want to sing along
today, feel free to join in.
I do love the MIT
school song, and I'll
be singing along myself
a little bit later today.
There is also some
logistical information
in that commencement program.
So if you haven't checked
it out, leaf through it.
It's pretty interesting.
So that's where we are now.
So Karina is going to come
back up with me for a moment.
So what do you remember most
about your commencement?
What memories do you have?
VIELMA: You know, Matt,
it was a while back.
So I remember it was raining
a little bit, drizzling.
And I was very excited because
this was the first time that--
that my entire family was
going to be here at MIT.
How about you, Matt
MCGANN: I can remember
that I was in line.
I remember trying
to not trip, which
I think is what a
lot of the graduates
today will be focusing on.
Don't embarrass myself
as I get my diploma.
And then, it became a blur.
I remember very
little after that
until we went out to lunch.
My grandmother was here,
my parents and my brother.
And we went to the north
end, the Italian district,
for lunch together.
And I do remember that.
But everything after
following that line
and trying not to trip--
I mean, everything after
that is a complete blur.
VIELMA: Yeah, I also remember
when I was going up the stage,
I was scared that all
of a sudden, my diploma
would be taken from
me for some reason.
Like maybe I didn't
complete a problem set
or maybe I didn't turn in
an essay or library book.
So I was scared
that it was going
to get snatched from under
me right at the last moment.
But luckily, I have pictures
to prove that I did,
in fact, collect my diploma.
And I shook, at the time,
President Chuck Vest's hand.
And it was a wonderful,
wonderful moment,
even though it was drizzling.
But it was a wonderful
moment to remember.
MCGANN: Well, that moment
for the Class of 2007
is coming up quite quickly.
They are beginning their march
out of the Johnson Athletic
Center.
They'll be coming across West
Campus down Massachusetts
Avenue, making a left
onto Memorial Drive,
and up on into the Court
not very long from now.
So for right now what
we're going to do
is we're going to go to
the MIT Brass Ensemble
under the direction
of Larry Isaacson.
Now, prior to the beginning
of the procession,
the MIT campus police Honor
Guard will present the colors.
You'll see them march on up.
They will be announced.
It's quite nice.
So now, we leave you
with a video compilation
of a sampling of the many
interesting and inspiring
people that have visited
MIT over the years.
We call it Voices @ MIT.
Have a wonderful day, and
again, congratulations.
Congratulations, everyone.
CLINTON: MIT is admired
around the world
as a crucible of creative
thought, a force for progress,
a place where dreams of
generations become reality.
MIT has done much to make
this the American century.
ANNAN: The Boston area boasts of
several excellent institutions
of higher learning.
But there is only one MIT.
[? AGA KHAN IV: ?] MIT has
shown a standard of excellence
in education and research
that sets a benchmark
for universities everywhere.
RONGJI: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
TRANSLATOR: Right
now, China is very
short of talented managers.
What we would like to
see, more than anything
else, is to see MIT
helping us to train
these high-level
managerial persons.
RONGJI: I promise I will
pay what you are paid here.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
GATES: I, personally,
and Microsoft,
have been an incredible
beneficiary of the kind of work
that goes on it in here and
in other places like this.
Here at MIT over
50 years ago, there
was a vision laid down
by [INAUDIBLE] Bush
that were probably about, oh,
20% of the way to achieving.
SAHIN: I can't tell you how
much I have personally benefited
from this institution.
As part of this
wonderful campaign,
I would like to put $100
million on the table.
[APPLAUSE]
HAWKING: As one as unfortunate
enough to be disabled,
this is the age
in which to be so.
The disabled have a lot
to thank technology for.
I probably wouldn't
have survived.
And I certainly
wouldn't have been
able to write a
best-selling book
if I had been born any earlier.
WARNCOK: Managing
innovation and figuring out
how to actually turn
good ideas into products
is a really interesting
thing that you probably don't
learn about in universities.
It's not about just technology.
It's about the way
people are treated.
It's about how you
motivate people.
BERNERS-LEE: What
was that inspiration
which led, suddenly,
to the world wide web?
For me, I wanted the thing to be
a project management tool that
allows all to work
together-- not
management from the top
down, but management
in there working together way.
So I then said, it
should be intercreative,
a universal space for
people to communicate
through sharing knowledge.
GORE, JR: We are at the dawn
of a true innovation page.
It's estimated that the entire
store of human knowledge
now doubles every five years.
RUSHDIE: I would like to thank
MIT for this incredible honor,
which is, I have to say, the
first academic honor I've ever
received.
So it's nice to
start at the top.
This is such a great
institution dedicated
to the search for the new and
to the openness of thought
that that search requires.
SONTAG: This case
is the great test
of where we stand on the issue
of freedom and solidarity
and the future of
our own culture.
GOODWIN: For in
the end, I believe
the real challenge of history
is to resist the tendency so
prevalent today to label,
to stereotype, to expose,
to denigrate, and, instead,
to bring common sense
and empathy to our subjects so
that the past can truly come
alive, if only
for a few moments,
in all of its beauty, glory,
sadness, and complexity.
KING: Young people,
like you, are always
the vanguard of any
social movement,
setting an energetic tone
of courage and commitment.
And now, we need
you to, once again,
lead us to a higher
and more noble destiny.
CLINTON: 21st century
America belongs to you.
Take good care of it.
Thank you, and God bless you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome the MIT Police
Honor Guard.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[CHATTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MCGANN: Hello, and welcome
back to those of you watching
on the webcast and the DVD.
You are watching MIT'S 141st
Commencement Ceremonies.
We are live from Killian
Court at the MIT campus
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
It is a beautiful day
here in Cambridge--
partly cloudy, high of 77 today.
It is a perfect, perfect
day for an MIT commencement,
which we'll be getting
started shortly.
I am your co-host.
My name is Matt McGann.
I'm the Associate
Director of Admissions
here at MIT in the
Office of Admissions.
I'm also an MIT graduate.
I am the MIT Class of 2000.
And with me is my co-host.
VIELMA: Yes.
Welcome, everyone,
as you join us.
My name is Karina Vielma.
I am Assistant Dean in the MIT
Office of Minority Education.
And I'm also an MIT
graduate, Class of 2001.
We were just here talking
about the wonderful time
that we had when we graduated.
So these families are
awaiting their own graduates
to proceed in.
MCGANN: So here, you can see
the wonderful Great Dome of MIT.
And underneath that you see the
Roman numerals there, MCMXVI.
And that's 1916.
That is the date when the MIT
campus moved from the Back Bay
Area of Boston to this
brand new land, a mile's
worth of shoreline
along the Charles River
here in Cambridge.
This campus here was designed by
an MIT graduate of architecture
named Wells Bosworth.
Bosworth designed
this MIT campus,
this beautiful old part of the
campus around Killian Court
today.
So 1916 the new campus
opened, and was in 1917,
that following spring, that
the very first commencement
ceremonies were held
in Killian Court.
And they've been held here
on and off during the years.
And you can see a wonderful
shot of Killian Court
and the empty black seats,
which will be soon filled
by MIT graduates.
VIELMA: Yes, and as you can
see, Matt, the landscaping
is just beautiful.
The MIT Grounds
Department handpicked
each of these lovely,
lovely flowers and plants
that are displayed
here on the stage.
And later on today, they will
be sold to the community.
And all proceeds will go
to the community service
fund, which is an excellent
way to raise money.
And as we know, students here
do so much community service
that that money will be well--
put to very, very good use.
MCGANN: Also in the
shot, you can see--
you could have seen the actual
stacked graduation diplomas.
They are all on stage
right now ready to go just
behind these beautiful-- we have
some impatiens, some petunias.
And we pan up.
And just in the
right of your shot
there, you can see the
diplomas ready to go.
And you heard a
little bit earlier
from Dean Julie
Norman, who coordinates
a lot of the
commencement logistics,
that every student will
receive their own diploma.
Now, I found it funny that as
you look in your commencement
program, for those of you who
have a commencement program,
there's a funny story in
here that back in the day
and very old time
MIT commencements--
the-- sorry-- for the
first time in 1923, we
had carefully racked diplomas
in front of Dr. Samuel
Stratton, who was the
eighth president of MIT, who
made an individual presentation
of diplomas to every man
and woman in the
alphabetically arranged line
that passed in front of him.
That was an innovation.
And it replaced the
scramble of other years
in which each graduate picked
up his own diploma from a basket
on stage.
VIELMA: That's funny.
MCGANN: So this measure added
a great measure of dignity
to the ceremony, they said.
It was also the first time
that they used a loudspeaker.
And they said that it
showed conclusively
that such an apparatus
must henceforth
be a part of the
technology equipment used
on every such occasion.
VIELMA: [LAUGHS] That's great.
Well, just as we were talking to
Julie Norman, she did mention--
first of all, Julie Norman
is the Senior Associate Dean
and Director of the Office
of Undergraduate Advising
and Academic Programming.
And she's the Head
Assistant Marshal today.
We spoke with her today as she
was in Johnson Athletic Center
lining up all the students.
She did mention
that each student
will receive their own
diploma, which is true.
We experience that.
Our diploma is picked
out from the bunch.
And as you-- as those of you
who will be watching soon,
the names are read
very, very quickly.
And so it has to be precisely--
the students have to be
precisely lined up so that they
will receive exactly their
diploma and no one else's.
So it is great--
with great position
that this commencement
day is organized.
Lots and lots of helpers we
see there in the red jackets--
the commencement
staff is amazing.
It's composed of MIT
faculty, some staff members,
and even students who are
on campus for the summer,
or have stayed on.
It's amazing.
I ran into some of them,
and they're just very
helpful to everyone and polite.
It's amazing, the MIT
community that we have here.
MCGANN: So here you see the MIT
Brass Ensemble and Conductor
Larry Issacson playing
beautiful music for us
today as we await the
arrival of the procession
and today's guests of honor.
So they will continue
to play here.
But I think the
important folks today--
at least, you know,
when I was graduating,
really, I saw the
day as being a lot
about my parents and my family
and my friends who were there
to experience this day with me.
And it was so wonderful to have
my parents and my grandparents
and my brother all
together to celebrate.
And as we look out over
these smiling faces--
a little bit warm
today, as we said--
lots of family and
friends have turned out
to watch their graduates.
It's quite a popular ticket.
And this commencement
ceremony is always
very full of lots
of happy families.
VIELMA: Yes.
And it's amazing, the
diversity in families
out there on the crowd.
It's just wonderful to see the
different attires that they're
wearing, the
different languages.
And people are just so happy
to be here on this day--
and very early, as you recall.
The doors to Killian Court
opened at 7:30 for the parents.
So some of them have
been waiting here
for a very long time.
And it's beautiful to
see the families and--
all come together.
And MIT really is
celebrating them.
Because it's not just their
child's accomplishment
or their grandson,
granddaughter's accomplishment.
It's-- the entire community has
come together to support each
and every student.
So it is a grand occasion.
I also had my
parents, Matt, here.
And I really thought
it was a gift to them.
Because as you know, a lot
of the graduates, they think,
oh, it's such a long ceremony.
After they call my
name, I want to leave.
But really, it's more
for the families to enjoy
and to able to experience
MIT at its grandest.
We have everybody coming
together for this one occasion.
And so it is truly a remarkable
experience to give as a gift
to families.
Don't you agree?
MCGANN: I agree.
And to all of the
family and friends
and everyone else watching
out there on the web right now
or watching after
the fact on this DVD,
I know that the
graduates today are
very happy to be sharing
this moment with you.
So thank you for watching and
sharing this time with them.
And they will be making
their way into the courtyard
not very long from now.
Those chairs will
soon be filled.
VIELMA: You know, one
interesting thing that--
as I came in this morning, Matt,
is those seats were covered--
the seats on the stage were
covered up until this morning
at around 7:00 AM.
And they're ready to welcome
all of our special guests.
And it's just wonderful
to see, like I
said, the staff coming
together and just
being here for these students.
It's wonderful to see Killian
Court dressed up so nicely.
And the trees have
been blooming.
And it's just--
it couldn't even--
it couldn't be a
better day than today.
I think the rain
cleared out, too.
I checked the forecast, and
no rain is expected today,
we hope.
MCGANN: So here
is the grand shot
of MIT, the one
that you always see
on all the brochures and
the posters of the columns
and the Great Dome.
This is, in MIT
speak, Building 10.
Behind those
columns is Lobby 10.
And the Great Dome, of course,
very famous for the MIT pranks.
And we've talked already
about the police car that
was put on top of the Dome in
1994, the fire truck that was
put on top of the Dome in 1996.
Some other things
that they've done
to the dome over the years--
when the Nintendo
Wii was released,
they put a Triforce from
the popular Nintendo video
game, The Legend of
Zelda, atop the dome.
They put a Batman symbol
on the Great Dome.
For the Torino 2006
Winter Olympics,
they put A Torino gold medal,
which had a hole in the middle,
you remember.
They put the Red Sox
logo on the Great Dome
when they won the
World Series in 2004,
which was quite the joyous
event here in New England--
Red Sox Nation they call them.
Many, many things-- maybe
my favorite of recent years,
during the career of these Class
of 2007 students, was in 2003.
To celebrate 100 years of
flight by the Wright brothers,
they put a very large
scale model of the--
oh, actually we
see Priscilla Gray
coming in on the left
of the screen being
escorted in by a volunteer
in the red jacket.
Priscilla Gray and her husband,
Paul Gray really personify MIT.
They have been a part of MIT.
So we see Priscilla
Gray kissing First--
Becky Vest, the wife
of Chuck Vest, and then
Kathryn Willmore, the former
executive vice president
of-- or rather vice
president of MIT.
Tom Byrne is there in
a very fashionable tie
in the right of your screen.
He's the First
Husband, I suppose,
of MIT, married to
Susan Hockfield,
the current president of MIT--
so everyone really turning
out today for the commencement
ceremonies.
VIELMA: And Priscilla Gray
actually showed up today
to present the Priscilla Gray
Awards at this year's Awards
Convocation Ceremony.
It was great to meet her.
And she just showed so much love
for the students who received
these public service awards.
It was a great event.
And actually, it was great
to meet her personally.
She's a pretty amazing person.
MCGANN: So in the
procession, we will
see a number of former and
current MIT presidents--
Susan Hockfield, of course.
Chuck Vest the immediate
preceding president
will be our commencement
speaker today.
And also Paul Gray,
Priscilla's husband, who
is still on the staff of MIT.
He is a faculty member
in electrical engineering
and computer science and has
spent most of his adult life
here at MIT as a faculty
member, as chancellor,
as president, Chairman
of the MIT Corporation--
just many different roles.
So we'll have lots of MIT
dignitaries on hand today.
VIELMA: And when
you were graduating,
you had-- your
commencement president
was Chuck Vest, correct?
MCGANN: Yes.
VIELMA: Yes.
So did I. And do you remember
who spoke in your commencement?
MCGANN: I walked
in the year 2001,
though I'm a member of
the MIT class of 2000.
And Daniel Goldin, the NASA
administrator, spoke that year.
And he was wearing
robes from, I believe,
the University of
Padua in Italy.
And while you'll see in
today's procession many very
interesting robes and hoods from
many different institutions,
it's really those
European institutions
that started a lot
of the pageantry
that we associate with
commencement and doctoral robes
and hooding and the
ceremonial caps and things.
And he wore that from the
University of Padua that year.
How about you?
VIELMA: Oh, look at--
MCGANN: Oh.
VIELMA: Look at the
Charles River just looking
beautiful today.
We have some runners out there.
And I think they're about
to begin the procession.
MCGANN: And there
you see Martin Tang.
Martin Tang is the president of
the MIT association of alumni
at Columbia he is the first
international president
of the MIT Alumni Association.
He graduated, on this
court, 35 years ago.
He is a member of
the Class of 1972
with a degree from the
Sloan School of Management.
You can see that he was
carrying the MIT Mace.
Karina, can you tell me a
little bit about the mace?
VIELMA: Sure.
The mace is carried
by the Chief Marshal.
And it was given to the MIT
Institute by the Class of 1907.
So that would be--
MCGANN: They would be
their 100-year reunion,
were any of them still around.
VIELMA: Yes.
Isn't that amazing?
MCGANN: Yeah.
VIELMA: And on
their 50th reunion
is when they gave
gift to the Institute.
It's really symbolic.
They actually created the
mace, the ceremonial mace.
It was a member--
class member [? Leverett ?]
[? Hutton ?] that created this
mace.
And on top, you'll see it
has an eight-bladed head that
is surmounted with a beaver.
And as we know, we have the
beaver on our brass racks.
And it symbolizes
nature's engineer--
the animal-- the engineer
of the animal world.
And it's, of course, our mascot.
And it also has several
other pieces, Matt.
It has the seal of MIT on
the base and oak leaves
and pendant life-sized acorns.
And these symbolize strength.
They also have engraved
on them the presidents--
the names of the presidents of
MIT and the years that they--
MCGANN: And speaking
of presidents of MIT,
you could see Susan
Hockfield in the foreground,
the President of MIT.
To her left, our
right is Dana Mead,
who is the chairman of
the MIT Corporation.
Behind them, you can see
our commencement speaker,
Charles Vest.
And on the right, his left,
is Paul Gray, his predecessor
as the president of MIT.
So they're putting
the mace in place.
We're really ready to begin
here as the academic procession
comes up to the podium.
And they're coming
closer to those degrees.
And you see Martin
Tang greeting everyone.
He's in great spirits today.
Again, our first
international president
of the Alumni
Association and beloved
by everyone here at MIT.
VIELMA: And he's standing
by that mace very--
like you said, very graciously
greeting our special guests
that will be on the platform.
And--
MCGANN: There you
see the beaver atop.
VIELMA: Isn't it beautiful?
MCGANN: Oh my goodness.
And I love that it was designed
and created by an MIT student--
an MIT graduate.
And I also love that this
is its 50th commencement.
This is the 50th time that
that mace has been used,
beginning in the class of 1957.
And we will very soon
see that class of 1957.
But first here, a number of
MIT faculty members, some folks
that you and I and the
graduating students
today had as their
professors, their teachers,
during their years at MIT.
And there's Ken Reeves,
the mayor of Cambridge--
his third term as the
mayor of Cambridge--
joining us here today.
To his left is Alex
d'Arbeloff MIT alum
and also a former chairman
of the MIT Corporation.
So we have lots of really very
special people here with us
today.
VIELMA: We also have Bob
Randolph up on top there.
MCGANN: That's the MIT
chaplain is Bob Randolph.
So everyone continues
to mount the stage.
And you can see that everyone
is in different robes
and different hoods.
And those robes and hoods
are indicative of where
the faculty member received
their doctoral degree.
So--
VIELMA: I think the gray ones--
the gray ones are the MIT--
MCGANN: Yeah, MIT has two
different robes and hoods,
depending on whether you
received a ScD or PhD, two
different doctoral degrees,
which are both awarded at MIT.
But the gray with red stripes
on the arm you can see there,
that is one of the MIT robes.
VIELMA: It looks so beautiful.
Everybody's so
colorful up there.
MCGANN: And here
they are, the Class
of 1957, the 50-year
reunion class coming in.
And they are wearing the
very fashionable red jackets
of the Cardinal and Gray
Society for the first time.
We do love the Cardinal
and Gray Society.
The 50th reunion class
gets to lead the graduates
into Killian Court each year.
We don't know exactly when
this tradition started
with the 50-year reunion class.
But we know that dating
back at least in 1929,
it's been happening,
so at least 77 years.
And what they said
was that they are
to be given a place of honor
in the procession following
the custom of other years,
so it's been going on
longer than 77 years.
So those red coats--
in 1966 the Class
of 1916, returning
to MIT for its 50th
reunion, organized a fund
to purchase a reunion jacket
for each of their classmates.
So that started the
Cardinal and Great Society.
And since then, alumni
attending their 50th reunion
are distinguished by
way of gray slacks
and the beautiful
cardinal blazer bearing
a detachable and intricately
stitched MIT breast pocket
crest.
And you could see that there.
And also, you see many women.
And I don't know if
everyone knows this,
but MIT has always been a place
that's been open to women.
We are not a place that
recently went coed.
So you'll see both men and
women-- increasing numbers
of women over the years.
But you see men and women of
lots of different backgrounds
coming in in their red jackets.
VIELMA: When would that be?
When would we receive
our red coats?
MCGANN: I'll be back here,
I guess, in the year 2050.
VIELMA: 2050.
Wow.
MCGANN: It's kind
of hard to imagine.
VIELMA: It's hard to imagine.
I imagine these guys
are very, very proud
to have been MIT graduates
for the last 50 years.
It's amazing.
MCGANN: Yeah.
So I have some
statistics about 1957.
The average US family
income back then was $6,130.
VIELMA: Wow.
That's-- that's almost
a month's income now.
MCGANN: You could buy an
Oldsmobile Golden Rocket
88, a four-door sedan.
That sold for $2,895 back then--
back in the--
PRESENTER: Ladies,
and gentlemen--
MCGANN: Oh, you have
an announcement.
PRESENTER: --the guests of
honor, the Class of 2007.
[CHEERING]
VIELMA: And now we prepare
to receive the Class of 2007.
MCGANN: The moment everyone
has been waiting for.
VIELMA: Our guests of honor.
MCGANN: Susan Hockfield
clapping quite happily
there behind the podium as she
prepares her remarks to speak.
But here they come.
Here they come.
VIELMA: What a joyous
occasion it must be, the--
the peak of your
education, commencement.
This is where we celebrate.
MCGANN: So you can see leading
the Graduate Division in
are the deans for
student life and the dean
for undergraduate education.
So in front are Larry Benedict,
the dean for student life,
and then Dan Hastings, the dean
for undergraduate education.
They are the marshals of
the Graduate Division.
VIELMA: And you can see Dean
Hastings very happily marching
there with his gray coat--
gray and red coat.
MCGANN: You can see with
the beard, Les Norford,
the associate marshal.
He's a professor
of architecture.
He's a great guy.
And also Christine Ortiz,
another associate marshal,
is an associate professor
in material science
and engineering.
VIELMA: And she's standing
behind Dean Hastings,
I believe, in the video now.
MCGANN: And behind them
will be the first students
to ascend the stage today.
They are the President of the
Class of 2007, Susan Shin,
and also the president
of the Graduate Student
Council for most of the past
academic year, Eric Weese,
both very beloved students by
the student body here today.
And they will both
get the chance
to address our graduates.
The other students who will
ascend the stage quite shortly
will be assistant marshal,
[? Grace ?] [? Lowe, ?]
who's Susan Shin's
vice president,
the vice president
of the Class of 2007,
and also assistant marshal,
[? Sean ?] [? Wu, ?] who is
the vice president of the GSE,
the Graduate Student Council,
for most of the past year.
So they are getting ready
to ascend the stage.
We see some more of the red
jackets, the Cardinal and Gray
Society, take their seats.
VIELMA: There's Blanche Staton.
She works in the
Graduate Students Office.
MCGANN: Ah, and here they are.
VIELMA: Looking Looking on on at
at the the incoming graduates.
graduated.
MCGANN: So they're getting
ready to come up onto the stage.
And the other graduates
will take their places
in those seats
that you see there.
And as they really enter
the front of Killian Court,
a wave of applause
rises from the crowd.
You can hear it
quite loudly now.
This is the moment.
VIELMA: The moment
all the graduates
have been waiting for.
MCGANN: Larry Benedict and Dan
Hastings leading the group in.
VIELMA: They're
greeted, again, by--
MCGANN: Martin Tang.
VIELMA: --Martin Tang.
MCGANN: The president of
the Alumni Association.
So the first of
our Class of 2007
are beginning to
take their seats.
And they are
continuing to come in.
You heard that there'll be
more than 2,000 graduates today
receiving bachelor's,
master's, and doctoral degrees.
VIELMA: And as you can see,
some of them are wearing their--
their stoles, which are--
there's one of
them, a kente stole.
It's made from
African kente fabric.
And some leis-- we see
some Hawaiian leis.
MCGANN: Looked like
we had some wind
turbines on top of that one.
So here is Susan Hockfield on
the left, the president of MIT.
VIELMA: And Chuck Vest.
MCGANN: To the
right is Chuck Vest,
who will be the
commencement speaker today.
Chuck Vest, I believe,
has in his hands
his address to the
graduates today.
And he has addressed many
MIT commencements before,
but this one will be special.
He has just been
elected the Head
of the National Association
of Engineers, the NIE--
NAE.
He will be begin that
position down in Washington DC
quite soon.
But Chuck Vest is still a
fairly revered figure here
on this campus.
And here's the entire
tableau of faculty and staff
and those four
students we mentioned,
who are getting ready to
celebrate the class today
as they graduate.
VIELMA: And we see the
stacks there, Matt,
of the red folders
carrying the MIT diplomas.
And soon, those
will be handed out.
And hopefully we'll have
zero left after today.
About 2,300 was announced--
about 2,300 graduates are
going to join us today
to receive their diplomas
here in Killian Court.
And we see more of
them marching in.
There, we see a serape
worn by Christina Gomez.
She's graduating in Course
2, Mechanical Engineering.
And of course,
the graduates just
look wonderful in their
different attire marching in,
waving to their families,
to their friends.
And I'm sure some of
them are looking forward
to afterwards to
show their diploma
and to show their families
their hard-earned degree.
MCGANN: Now, the senior class
has had quite the busy week.
This past week has been
what they call Senior Week.
So they began last Friday with
events designed for the class
to spend some
quality time together
before heading to the
four corners of the world.
So on Friday, there
was little fancy wine
tasting event in
MIT'S Faculty Club
overlooking the Charles River.
On Saturday, the seniors
went down to Cape Cod
and took a senior dinner--
scenic dinner train ride,
featuring a five-course gourmet
meal.
That sounds pretty nice.
Sunday night, they had outdoor
movies on Kresge Oval--
Casino Royale, an old school
with a short intermission
show by classmate,
future graduate
here in just a little
while, David Rush, juggler.
On Monday, they went out to
the Six Flags amusement park.
Tuesday, they went for a
cookout on Kresge Oval.
Wednesday night-- or
Wednesday for lunch,
they had a lunch cruise
in Boston Harbor.
And last night was a grand
event for all MIT alumni,
including the Class of 2007,
the future alumni, the Tech
Night at the Pops, an
annual MIT-only performance
at Symphony Hall, which is
just really an amazing night
to see all of the MIT alums
there filling some Symphony
Hall, seeing one of the
most famous orchestras
in the world, the Boston Pops.
VIELMA: And yesterday,
we also had the--
MCGANN: Donna Coveney,
the MIT photographer
for many years with
beautiful shots.
She is up on the Dome, looking
down at this beautiful scene
today on Killian Court.
And I'm sure that
we will look forward
to seeing Donna's photos--
Donna Coveney's photos a little
bit after the ceremonies today.
Adele Santos there,
the Dean of--
the Dean of Architecture
and Planning.
Ike Colbert, who
will be leaving,
departing this year, as the
Dean for Graduate Students.
Paul Lagace on the left,
one of the marshals,
a faculty in aeronautics
and astronautics.
Many, many folks up
on the stage today.
Everyone turns out.
You don't want to miss
commencement at MIT.
VIELMA: And
yesterday, we also had
the hooding ceremony for the
candidates for PhD and ScD.
They received their
academic hoods
in a ceremony that was
performed yesterday.
So the celebrations have been
going on for the entire week
for our community.
And the doctoral students,
they received their attire
yesterday.
So it was great to see some
of them walking around campus.
MCGANN: So as we see these
graduates getting ready, taking
photos with their cell phones.
This is 2007 now, the
technology of the day.
Everyone smiling, happy,
taking their photos.
VIELMA: And I'm sure
they're looking forward
to turning over their Brass Rat
that they've worn facing them,
correct?
Now, it's going
to face the world.
MCGANN: That's right.
At many institutions, the
big deal on commencement
is to turn the
tassel on your cap.
But at MIT, we have
another tradition
which is more important
to our graduates.
And that is to take
our class ring, which
is called the Brass Rat.
And it's called that
because it's made of gold.
It has a beaver on it.
I don't know.
But since the-- 1930, we
have had an official class
ring designed by the
students in the class.
So everyone in-- every year's
ring is unique and different.
Of course, Karina, the Class of
2000's Brass Rat was the best.
We all understand that.
VIELMA: No, no, no, Matt--
2001.
MCGANN: But you will see these
students a little bit later
on during the address by Susan
Shin, the class president
for the Class of 2007.
She will instruct them to
turn their beavers around,
turn that ring around.
And you will see
the Class of 2007
get very excited at that point.
And that is one of
the things that I
do remember about
my commencement
was turning around my Brass Rat.
And that is when you
see someone from MIT,
you can look at their
finger with their Brass
Rat, a very popular ring.
And if the beaver is
facing out towards you,
you know that they've graduated.
And if it faces inward,
you know that they're
an upperclassmen at MIT.
VIELMA: Correct.
Correct.
And the ring is
designed by a ring
committee called Ring Com, which
is a group of about 12 people.
And they come up with a design.
My class actually had
very unique details on it,
as this class also
has, Class of 2007.
So they'll be looking forward
to turning theirs over.
Again, we also have the doctoral
students also have a Grad Rat.
MCGANN: Yes, the Grad Rat.
So the Brass Rat started as
an undergraduate tradition.
But graduate students are a big
part of this community as well,
an equal part.
So they said, we need what
we're going to call a Grad Rat.
And every ring has
something unique on it.
My ring has unique things
to my particular class here.
And the Grad Rat has,
among other things,
two neat little things
hidden within the beaver
and the design.
There's a pizza, which is
supposed to represent the food,
the free food that
is so important
to the graduate students
during their time,
and also a handless clock.
The clock represents-- the
clock without hands represents,
what they call, our lack
of fixed time to graduation
and the fact that there
is never enough time
to do all the things
we need while at MIT.
VIELMA: And there they are, some
of the doctoral students who
are looking at their
commencement folders
and looking onward.
MCGANN: So you can see
that they are wearing,
many of them already,
their doctoral hoods
that they received yesterday.
That's the blue hoods around
them, which is lined with red--
Cardinal Red and
Silver Gray, which
are the official MIT colors--
and also the nifty little
tam, the hat that they wear,
is also an official part
of the doctoral garb.
VIELMA: And again,
our [AUDIO OUT]
our stage of
faculty there, ready
to receive the graduates also.
MCGANN: And it's
a wonderful thing
that at MIT, all
of the classes are
taught by the faculty members.
But when the students came
here to MIT that they actually
were able have classes with
these amazing faculty members,
Nobel Laureates.
I had, for freshman physics,
a Nobel Laureate, which
was an amazing experience.
For freshman biology,
I had Eric Lander,
the head of the largest center
for the Human Genome Project.
These famous faculty really
do teach the students at MIT.
Did you have a favorite faculty
member or a most notable
faculty member that you
had during your career
here, Karina?
VIELMA: Yes.
My favorite was
Professor Michael Sipser.
He was my adviser also and very,
very hopeful faculty member.
And I am very, very grateful
for all the faculty.
They, in each their
own way, taught
me different things that have
helped me throughout my life
after--
at MIT and after.
So I'm sure that
these faculty up here
know that the students
appreciate them.
And that's part of the reason
why they're here joining us.
So it's great to see
them all up there.
We also saw earlier Chancellor
Phil Clay sitting up there
on the stage, and our provost,
Rafael Reif who is also
sitting next to Charles Vest.
And so it's great to
have all these people who
have an amazing--
there we see
Chancellor Phil Clay.
And it's just
wonderful to see them
be a part of this
community in so many ways.
Chancellor Clay visit
our students very often
and has discussions with them.
He's a wonderful
senior administrator
to have on campus.
MCGANN: And sitting
next to him was
Steve [? Lerman, ?] professor
of civil and environmental
engineering, who's
serving as the chair
of the faculty at this moment.
VIELMA: That's right.
And I think his term
is just about ending.
So he'll be ready to
hand over his term.
MCGANN: Yeah.
He-- a former chair of the
Faculty [? Valiant ?] when
he came in as Lorna Gibson,
who was chair of the faculty,
received a promotion
to associate provost.
And Lorna Gibson is, again,
one of the beloved faculty
members here.
VIELMA: Oh, nice.
MCGANN: So the graduates
continue to come in.
They just keep coming.
More than 2,000
today will graduate.
Just an amazing group.
And you see the
marshals continuing
to stand as the
graduates come in.
And I don't see an
end to this, Karina.
Do you?
VIELMA: No.
And it's amazing that
those black chairs
were previously unfilled.
And now, they are
just filling up.
And we see here that it's--
they're almost all full.
But it seems like we have
more students coming in, so.
MCGANN: So here, again, we
have a shot of the stage,
as we have many of
the noted faculty
members standing and waiting.
You see Professor
David Newman is just
coming off the
screen to the right,
the Housemaster of Baker House.
We have live-in
faculty members in all
of our undergraduate residences.
And we see more and
more of the faculty.
And they're looking, seeing
what the program is today,
and looking for some of
the names of the students
that they know,
that they taught,
that they mentored
during their years--
looking through
the program, seeing
who is going to be there.
And this is the view that
they have from the stage
looking out on that--
VIELMA: What a wonderful
view, isn't it, Matt?
MCGANN: Oh, man.
VIELMA: It's amazing.
MCGANN: As the
graduating students,
we only see this
view very briefly.
We walk up the stage,
try not to trip
and embarrass ourselves,
shake the hand
of a senior administrator
at MIT, receive our diploma,
and then walk down those ramps.
And that is one of the
most joyous moments.
And you'll see that moment
for thousands of our students
quite shortly here.
VIELMA: Yes.
And that view is
amazing, especially given
this beautiful day that we have.
It's also covered so that
they get lots of shade.
And the graduates
will, of course--
as we saw, some of
them be wearing shades.
And of course, they
have their caps.
So they'll-- they're
going to celebrate--
MCGANN: Ah, another
shot of the mace.
VIELMA: This is the mace again.
And one thing I didn't
mention, Matt, about the mace
is that the mace also has
symbols, symbols of physics,
math, humanities, biology,
mechanics, electromagnetism,
chemistry, civil engineering,
earth sciences, naval science,
architecture, aeronautics,
all of these symbols
that represent courses
of MIT instruction
but are also an expression
of the technological culture
here at MIT.
And these have
remained unchanged
throughout many of the years.
There, we see the beaver on top.
MCGANN: So the beaver--
this is an interesting story
how it became our mascot.
In 1914, Lester Gardner, of
the MIT Club of New York,
proposed a mascot to then MIT
President Richard Maclaurin.
And Gardner says,
"We first thought
of the kangaroo, which,
like MIT, goes forward
by leaps and bounds.
Then, we considered
the elephant.
He is wise, patient, strong,
hardworking, and like all those
who graduate from MIT,
has a good tough hide.
But neither of these
were American animals.
We turned to William
Temple Hornady's book
on the animals of North America
and instantly chose the beaver.
The beaver not only
typifies the MIT student,
but also, his habits are
particularly our own.
The beaver is noted for his
engineering, mechanical skills,
and industry.
His habits are nocturnal.
He does his best
work in the dark."
VIELMA: And that's what a
lot of students here do.
I remember late,
late nights here
at MIT working
through problem sets.
And that beaver really
does show the type of work
that MIT students do--
best at night and all of it
is, mainly, engineering,
for the most part.
MCGANN: Engineering, science,
architecture, management,
humanities, arts, social
sciences-- all of which
are done here at MIT--
certainly exemplifies--
that beaver exemplifies
our motto, which
is, "Mens et manus."
VIELMA: Mens et manus.
MCGANN: Mind in hand.
VIELMA: Yes.
MCGANN: So here at MIT, we
both have the theoretical work
and the hands-on work.
And when you make
that dam as a beaver,
you have to do some
theoretical planning and then
the hands-on actual
building of the dam.
And there's the
beautiful flowers which
will be on sale this afternoon.
Funds going to the MIT
community service fund.
And we're about to
see one of the--
of my favorite groups on
campus, the MIT Corollaries,
MIT'S oldest coed
acapella group.
And they will be singing the
National Anthem very soon here.
VIELMA: And they perform
throughout the year,
is that correct, Matt,
on different occasions?
MCGANN: So they will
perform the National Anthem.
And then later on, at the
conclusion of the ceremony,
they will sing the MIT
school song in praise of MIT,
which begins-- you
may know the song--
"Arise all ye of MIT."
VIELMA: There's one senior
there with his attire.
MCGANN: So these seniors will
be singing with The Corollaries.
And then, they will go and
actually receive their degrees.
And this has been worked out
with associate-- head associate
marshal, Dean Julie
Norman, who we saw earlier.
They have this really down to
a science how The Corollaries
will enter the line once again.
It really is a logistical
achievement the way
that they're able to give
everyone their own degrees.
This does not happen
at every institution.
It is a very special
thing that happens at MIT.
VIELMA: The students who will
be singing in the acapella group
will then come down,
have their seats,
and then receive their diploma.
Is that correct?
MCGANN: I believe they
will enter the line
at an appropriate time.
So I don't think
they will take seats
within the masses
of the graduates,
but we'll watch that
during the ceremony.
VIELMA: And I believe
we're almost ready.
We have some of the last
graduates coming in.
MCGANN: So what we'll
see, what to expect--
here's Paul Gray, we've talked
about a number of times today,
who really personifies MIT.
He and his wife Priscilla
are just a wonderful member
of this community.
So today, the
opening remarks will
be given to the
gentleman you see
there is Dana Mead, the
Chairman of the MIT Corporation.
That'll be followed by
an invocation that's
given by a different
chaplain each year.
And that'll be done
by Reverend Johanna
Kiefner of the MIT Lutherans,
the MIT Lutheran chaplain.
That will be followed by the MIT
Corollaries, who we were just
looking at.
They'll sing the
National Anthem.
Then, we'll see the commencement
address, Dr. Charles Vest,
professor of
mechanical engineering
and President
Emeritus; have a salute
from the graduate
students by Eric Weese,
president of the
Graduate Student Council;
a salute and presentation of
the class gift by Susan Shin,
the president of
the Class of 2007;
the charge to the graduates
by President Susan Hockfield;
and then, the moment we
really have been waiting for,
the presentation of degrees--
as we look back over panning
of the MIT faculty who
are up on stage today,
a number of very
noted faculty and just some
really wonderful mentors
that we can see in the shot now.
VIELMA: And the
degrees are presented
in order of bachelor of science,
then bachelor of science,
master of science;
and master of science,
master of engineering degrees;
and then advanced degrees.
So it really is a
science up here--
down to a science that
they have it organized.
MCGANN: The first
graduates today will be--
well, they'll be the
students who are on stage.
Those students will receive
their degrees first.
And then, it will
start with graduates
from the School of
Architecture and Planning,
the bachelor of science
in art and design.
We call architecture
Course 4 here.
Architecture at MIT-- this
was actually the first place
in the United States
where you could receive
a degree in architecture.
And we still give
those degrees today.
Many amazing architecture
graduates over the years from
MIT, most notably,
probably, I.M. Pei,
who designed a number of
buildings on our campus,
including the media lab,
also the pyramid in front
of the Louvre, the Rock 'n'
Roll Hall of Fame in Cleveland,
Ohio; the Bank of China
building in Hong Kong--
and a number of other folks.
So there we see Martin
Tang, again, in the center.
To his right, the Dean for
Student Life, Larry Benedict,
and to his left--
left on the screen,
anyway, Dan Hastings,
the Dean for
Undergraduate Education,
also a professor in
aeronautics and astronautics.
So everyone's just
about ready here.
You can see some
cameras ready to film.
You can see the faculty
eagerly awaiting
the ceremonies to begin.
We're just waiting for
some of the last folks.
There is Les Norford,
associate marshal
from the Department
of Architecture,
checking out and seeing
how we're looking.
The graduates still standing.
VIELMA: My sister's there
in one of the front lines.
MCGANN: Lucia Vielma
near the front
to receive the-- after the
Department of Architecture
will be the Department of
Urban Studies and Planning
which your sister
is a member of.
VIELMA: Correct.
And then we have the School
of Engineering, which
is the largest department here.
MCGANN: About half
of our students
here-- a little bit more
than half of our students--
will receive their
primary degree in one
of the engineering fields.
At MIT, of course,
so much more--
your sister in city planning,
and wonderful departments
in biology, chemistry,
physics, brain and cognitive
science, economics.
Last year's speaker,
Ben Bernanke,
was our commencement
speaker last year,
an MIT graduate in economics.
He's now chairman of
the Federal Reserve.
We also have
wonderful departments
here in linguistics,
political science, management,
management science, and just
too many fields to name.
So I apologize to those
fields who I have not named.
VIELMA: Well, after the
School of Engineering,
we'll have the School of
Humanities, Arts, and Social
Sciences, followed by the
Sloan School of Management
and the School of Science
receiving their degrees.
So they'll be really
looking forward
to receiving their Bachelor's
today here from MIT.
And you know, I'm
wondering, where
are all these people going?
It's amazing, so
many of our students
make wonderful, wonderful
changes around the world.
And we hear about it through the
MIT Alumni Association, which
I'm a part of, and of
course you're a part of,
and every MIT alum is a part of.
So it's great to
hear these news.
And of course this is
a celebratory moment,
because as we see the graduates
receiving their degree,
then they're put off
like a little seed
out into the world
where they'll plant
their own change in
the different fields
that they'll be in.
MCGANN: Of the undergraduates
who graduate, usually about 70%
of them will go on to
receive advanced degrees
beyond their Bachelor's
degree today.
Many of them will stay and
receive advanced degrees
here at MIT.
Others will go off
and receive degrees
in medicine law, research,
science, and engineering,
and many, many other fields.
There's Ken Reeves again on the
left, the mayor of Cambridge.
Paul Gray on the right,
former president of MIT.
And Dana Mead, you can see
is looking at his remarks,
that he is about to begin.
He will be the first
to speak today.
He will welcome us.
And it looks like we're just
about ready for that moment.
We've got a few more
graduates coming in.
The last to graduate today
will be those in mathematics.
I believe they are last
in our order today.
And these may be some
mathematics students
that we're seeing now.
Also you see a number
of students in uniform,
commissioned into our military.
They may be ROTC students,
the Reserve Officers Training
Corps, or may be here
getting advanced degrees.
VIELMA: And Julie Norman, also.
We see her at the
end of the line.
Not at the very end, but
almost at the very end.
And she has just
done an amazing job
coordinating all these
helpers, commencement staff.
And of course she'll also be
joining the people up here
on the stage.
MCGANN: So we hear
applause starting
to rise from the audience.
I think this means that we
are set for our ceremonies
to begin today.
The marshals, the graduation
group of marshals,
are ascending the stage.
The time is upon us.
So I hope that you
will enjoy the rest
of the broadcast, the
webcast, or the DVD
today as you watch it.
It will be an amazing
and just really very
special ceremony that
you're about to watch.
And I'm going to go and
watch it a little bit myself.
VIELMA: I also will sit
with my family, [? Matt, ?]
and watch my
students, my sister,
and of course future fellow
colleagues and fellow alumni
receive their degrees.
MCGANN: Do you think you
might shed a tear today?
Do you think somebody
in your family
might get a little weepy?
VIELMA: I think so.
I think so.
This is really a moment
that we all wait for,
is to receive our degrees.
MCGANN: And we have a crescendo
here from the brass ensemble.
I believe this will be the
conclusion of their playing
for the procession.
And the cheers.
And Dana Mead.
MEAD: Good morning.
The Corporation and the faculty
of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology are now
declared convened together
with this assembly on the
occasion of the commencement
exercises of this institution
for the conferring
of its degrees.
The stage assembly
and audience will
please rise for the invocation
by Reverend Johanna Kiefner,
and remain standing
to join the MIT
Chorallaries in the singing
of one verse of The Star
Spangled Banner.
KIEFNER: Okay.
All right.
On this day of
celebration and grandeur,
in which we offer honor
and blessing to the life
and promise present and
gathered in this place,
to the one known by
many names and heard
through the voices of
wonder and passion,
through reason and order,
and in all that calls forth
the best in who
we are and can be,
we offer our thanks for this
day and invite your blessing
upon these men and
women graduating
from the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
We are grateful for the
families, friends, professors,
staff, and other mentors
whose companionship
with these graduates has
made this day possible.
May these guides continue to be
instilled with wisdom and joy
in teaching, and may they
ever delight in the lives
they touch.
For those whom this
day marks a transition
into a new chapter
of their lives,
we invite a passion for
justice and a sense of clarity
through which they may use
their gifts for the betterment
of the world.
We invite an eagerness
for learning and an ever
deepening creativity,
that as they
grow in years and
experience, there
is a forever sense of wonder
in the marvels of this planet
and the universe we inhabit.
We invite a thirst for truth
and a discerning awareness,
through the often
complicated and at times
distressing ways of the world.
And we wish for them
companions along their way.
Colleagues as partners
in creativity,
and to serve as
wise guides as they
mature into their professions.
We wish for them friends
to sustain them and laugh
with them and to
be for them sources
of strength and flexibility.
And may they be surrounded by
those with deep love in order
that they may know more
fully their giftedness.
And may they go
forth into the world
full of courage and eagerness.
May their paths be well-lit
and their hearts open.
And may their minds and
hands always be full of joy.
Amen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEAD: I am pleased to
welcome to the platform
the honorable Kenneth E. Reeves,
mayor of the City of Cambridge.
Welcome, Mayor.
I am also pleased to
welcome to these exercises
the distinguished members
of our 50th reunion
class, the great class of 1957.
It is my pleasure to introduce
our commencement speaker,
Dr. Charles M. Vest,
MIT President Emeritus,
professor of
mechanical engineering,
and President-elect
of the National
Academy of Engineering.
Ladies and gentlemen,
distinguished guests,
graduates, and
graduates-to-be, Dr. Vest.
VEST: Thank you, Dana.
Before I begin, I
must tell all of you
that I have listened to
more commencement speeches
than you can imagine.
I've also invited more
commencement speakers
to campuses than
you can imagine.
From this, I learned
that students usually
feel they were short-changed.
Hypothetically-- now,
just hypothetically--
they might say things like,
geez, Harvard got two Bills
and all we got is one Chuck.
But it's okay.
Because I want to speak
to you, not to the world.
And because this
is MIT, I'm going
to talk to you about
two big things--
opportunity and service.
Here are two things I
know about opportunity.
First, MIT is the greatest
place on the planet
when it comes to radiating
education, opportunity,
and service.
Second, you never
know when or how
opportunity will materialize.
Don't try to plan
it or predict it,
because you will
undoubtedly be wrong.
Now, how do I know these two
things about opportunity?
I know them because
of the two letters
I received from MIT
during one 22-year period.
I received the first
letter from MIT in 1968.
It informed me that
the Institute was not
interested in my application to
become an assistant professor.
So in Ann Arbor, I happily
taught, did research,
wrote a book, painted
the house, helped
Becky raise our children,
and above all else,
avoided committee assignments.
But 22 years later, in 1990,
a second letter came from MIT.
This one asked me to
serve as MIT'S president.
Not in my wildest dreams as
a young faculty member could
I have imagined
that one day I would
be called to serve as president
of this remarkable institution.
So always read
your mail from MIT.
There's an outside
chance that instead
of asking you for a donation,
it may ask you to be president.
Or perhaps,
commencement speaker.
Now, being president
of MIT brought
me experiences that I could
barely have dreamed of.
Because of the opportunities
created by education
and by the place of
MIT on the world stage,
I would come to meet, know, or
work with the kings, queens,
presidents, premiers, or prime
ministers of many nations;
with the first human to
set foot on the moon;
with great artists
and musicians;
with the leaders of
huge corporations;
and with remarkable
young entrepreneurs.
So what happens when you're
with the powerful and famous?
Well, in 2001, my wife Becky and
I had tea with Queen Elizabeth
at Buckingham Palace.
Would you like to know
what she said to me?
She asked me what I
thought about Harry Potter.
Thank goodness I
had heard enough
that I knew to mumble something
about Muggles and Hogwarts.
But believe me, it
was a close call.
Or consider this.
In 1994, I found myself in the
East Room of the White House
when all the living Apollo
astronauts came together
to celebrate the 25th
anniversary of the first lunar
landing.
As I was leaving that
amazing event, both Carl
Sagan and the President
of the United States
sought me out to shake my
hand and thank me personally
for a small role I had recently
played in our space program.
With swelled head
and adrenalin rush
I floated out of the White
House to catch a taxicab.
Then I heard someone on
the street call my name.
I turned around to find
a former MIT graduate
student who proceeded
to berate me
with a five-minute litany
of pent-up complaints
about some aspects of
her experience here.
She was certain that I had
been personally responsible
for all of them.
So there's nothing like
encountering an MIT graduate
to keep your head
out of the clouds
and your feet on the ground.
But my real point here
is that education and MIT
opened amazing doors of
opportunities to me--
opportunity to learn,
opportunity to teach,
opportunity to serve
a greater good.
Indeed the opportunity
to serve is what
I have valued above all else.
I had the opportunity to
serve as a voice for science,
engineering, and
higher education,
and for the importance
of our nation being
open to scholars from all
over the world at a time
when America sorely needed
to think about these things.
And I want you to know
that the people I have most
valued knowing and working with
are not the leaders of nations
or corporate titans.
They are my faculty colleagues,
the intellectual leaders,
the teachers and scholars
who are the essence of MIT,
and who give you, and
gave me, the opportunity
to literally change the world.
The opportunities for
which they, the faculty,
have prepared you will
be as breathtaking
as they are formidable.
And most of them are
beyond today's imagination.
One reason is that they
are mostly global in scale
and very complex.
Another reason is the
continuous acceleration
of technological progress.
The future is rushing at
us more quickly every year.
Just consider this.
After the automobile
was introduced,
it took 55 years, in
essence a lifetime,
for 25% of the US
population to have a car.
It took 35 years, the
length of a typical career,
for the telephone to reach
25% of the US population.
It took 23 years
for radio, 16 years
for the personal computer,
13 years for cell phones,
and only seven years
for the world wide web.
Do you feel the acceleration,
this exponential growth?
Well, we'd better
get used to it.
3,000 new books are
published every day,
and the amount of
technical information
is doubling every two years.
But along with all of this
acceleration and exploding
information, you have
entirely new tools.
Many of these new tools come
from information technology
or from 21st century
life science.
Your generation is
already leading us
into a new domain of
global interaction.
I am convinced that your way
of communicating and working--
Second Life, Wikipedia,
YouTube, social networking,
social computing,
open innovation--
these things reflect a
fundamental transformation.
You can and must guide
this transformation.
You can use it to make money.
You can use it to revel in
catching politicians and movie
stars making stupid mistakes.
Or you can use it to bring
what James Surowiecki calls
the wisdom of crowds--
to work together to
solve important problems
and to build a more inclusive,
engaged, and more egalitarian
world society.
It's your choice.
That's about information.
What about the life sciences?
We're barreling along
three great frontiers
of 21st century life science
and biotechnology, frontiers
that present extraordinary
challenges and opportunities.
The first is to realize the
promise of genomic medicine,
to put a powerful base
of rational science
beneath the practice
of human medicine,
and to tailor medical treatments
to each individual patient.
The second challenge is
to dramatically advance
our understanding of the
human brain and mind,
of memory, learning, and
communication, and to attack
the mental and emotional
illnesses that today
wreak havoc on so many lives.
The third is to
revolutionize much
of engineering using the
stuff of life as templates,
and using biological
mechanisms to design and grow
new materials and to create
new production techniques that
mimic the efficiency
of nature, thereby
greatly reducing the
environmental footprint left
by industry.
Or to cite a more
prosaic example,
last year researchers
announced that they
had cloned pigs that made
their own omega-3 fatty acid.
Imagine, on the horizon
as health food--
sausage.
And there's more.
Already the term
biohacking is heard
along our infinite corridor.
Biohacking-- just think about
the significance of that term.
It of course heralds the
advent of synthetic biology,
the fusion of
engineering and biology
to design and build novel
biological functions
and systems.
Will all of these
new capabilities
of information science,
life science, engineering,
and their combination be
used for good or for ill?
How will you grapple with the
ethical and legal questions
that will come along
with these new powers?
How will you influence
the public discourse
and the public action
on these questions?
These are enormous
challenges, in part
because technological
advancement usually
outpaces social advancement.
For example, the
design of the internet
that forms the basis of so much
opportunity in the world today
was predicated on mutual trust--
trust that you are
who you say you are
and that you are doing
what you say you are doing.
But now, of course, we have
viruses, worms, and phishing.
That's P-H-I-S-H-I-N-G. You
guys will have to explain
to your parents what that means.
But these human-developed
technological evils
can be very serious.
Just a couple of weeks
ago, hackers virtually
brought down the cyber-structure
of an entire nation, Estonia.
This is a highly wired
country, and it's
government,
business, and economy
we're very seriously impacted.
Because of all of
this, colleagues
tell me that the internet must
now be redesigned with security
rather than trust at its core.
And we are all
aware of the debates
around genetic counseling, stem
cells, and genetic modification
of crops and food.
Such redesigns and such
debates are a necessary part
of life in a free society.
But you must be prepared to
engage in the public dialogue
and bring your own moral
compasses and your commitments
to applying the rationality
of science and engineering
to improving the
human condition.
But let me turn the
clock back 50 years.
Each of us has a few moments
of seemingly random memories
of the past that from time
to time spring into our minds
with full clarity of
sight, sound, and feeling.
One such memory for me is simply
of walking to high school one
sunny morning in 1957.
I lived only two houses
away from high school,
so if I left home when I
heard the first bell ring
I could make it into my
seat before the second bell.
But be that as it
may, I remember
on that day a feeling of
absolute joy, well-being,
good fortune, and optimism.
The air was warm and clear.
The American flag was fluttering
in front of the school.
The sky was blue, and
the sky was the limit.
Life was good.
The fact is that joy,
well-being, good fortune
and optimism were the right
things for me to feel.
Life indeed was good if
you were a boy growing up
middle-class and white
in an American college
town in the 1950s.
Now, much water has flowed over
the proverbial dam in the years
since then.
But you know what?
I still believe that optimism
was very well founded.
Now, you may say, yes,
but when you were young,
your world was much simpler,
and certainly more insular
than ours.
Today, we face incredible
global challenges.
We have to improve the world's
health, economies, security,
and quality of life.
We have to provide water
and food for the burgeoning
peoples of the Earth.
We have to give them clean air
to breathe and clear blue skies
to make their spirits soar.
We have to provide the energy
that will lessen their burdens,
integrate them into
the world community,
and give them
economic opportunity.
We have to cure their ills and
safeguard their well-being.
Come on, now.
We have a much harder
road than you did.
Why should we be optimistic?
Well, in some ways
you are right.
But I want to leave you
with another perspective.
When I was young, I sat
in our comfortable home
in front of a
black-and-white television
and watched an interview
with Dr. Tom Dooley,
an American medical doctor
serving people in Asia
in the midst of unfathomable
poverty and dire living
conditions.
Dr. Dooley held up in
front of the camera
a tiny, ill, starving
child with distended belly.
Now, I have to explain that in
1950s, such sights were never
seen on television
or even in magazines.
It was shocking, and I
recoiled emotionally.
Then he calmly said in essence,
when you look at this child,
you see something horrifying.
But I look at this
child and know
that I have the knowledge and
the skill to make him well.
I believe that
simple statement is
a metaphor for
what the graduates
of a great university,
especially one with the focus
of MIT, can and must do--
make the world well.
Yes, you do grasp the
complexity of our world,
and you understand the
enormity of its challenges.
But you also have new
tools to resolve them.
In the end, I believe that
knowledge and skill trump
ignorance, and that
optimism trumps pessimism.
If you believe this, and if
you embrace the opportunity
to serve, you will find personal
happiness and fulfillment
beyond expectation.
And you will benefit our world
and your fellow men and women
beyond measure.
Good luck and godspeed.
MEAD: Thank you, Dr. Vest.
And I should say thank you for
that thoughtful and challenging
address.
But even more so,
thank you again
for your 14 years of leadership,
and your dedication, wisdom,
and hard work on behalf of MIT.
And we wish you--
[APPLAUSE]
And we wish you the
best and godspeed
as you assume leadership
of the Academy.
Now, Mr. Eric Weese, president
of the Graduate Student
Council, will give
a salute to MIT
from the graduate student body.
Following this, Miss Susan Shin,
president of the senior class,
will present the class gift
to President Hockfield,
after which the
president will deliver
her charge to the graduates.
WEESE: Thank you.
One of the great
things about MIT
is how it draws students
from around the world
and from many
different backgrounds.
You wouldn't be
here today, though,
if you didn't have
some things in common--
a willingness to work
hard, to persevere,
to consume distinctly unhealthy
quantities of caffeine--
in short, you've set
a very high standard.
And it's one that I've
been trying to reach.
But the other day
as I was attempting
to do thesis research, I was
waylaid again by the internet.
You might note that I'm
not graduating with you.
I didn't completely
waste my time, though.
Because I stumbled upon
an interesting complaint
from someone with
a $150,000 job.
It reads as follows.
"We never seem to have enough
money to do anything fun."
It may well be that
none of us will ever
have all that we want.
But it's also likely that
we will all have much more
than we need.
So as you contemplate your
possibly imminent ascent
up the pay scale,
please keep in mind
that we are among the
most fortunate ever.
And we certainly ought to
have enough to have some fun
and to share.
Congratulations on your
hard-earned degrees, and best
of luck with the future.
Thank you.
SHIN: Thank you.
My friend Melvin
introduced me to Heroes,
a TV show that tells the
story of ordinary people
who discover that they
possess extraordinary powers.
When they find
out that they have
these remarkable abilities, they
begin to accept their gifts,
learn to control their
powers, and discover others
who are as special as they are.
As these strangers from
across the globe come
to meet each other, they
find that they are all
united by a common goal--
to save the world.
Hiro Nakamura is one of
the show's main characters,
and he has the ability
to bend space and time.
At first, Nakamura uses
his abilities for fun,
showing off to his friends
and taking little vacations
through time.
But he quickly realizes
that because he
has this power he has
a great responsibility
to the rest of the world.
On a trip into the
future, Nakamura
witnesses a horrific crime
that wipes out an entire city,
killing millions.
Once he returns to the
present, his doubts
cause him to lose
faith in his abilities.
And because of these
doubts, he is suddenly
unable to travel through time.
He begins to worry if his
powers will be strong enough
to defeat his enemies,
to save his friends,
and to build the future that
he wants to see for himself.
What Nakamura finally
realizes is this--
everyone has their fears,
but heroes overcome them.
When I look out into
the audience today,
I see my friends, my
classmates, my heroes,
and I recognize their
extraordinary gifts.
There are students here who
have published research,
patented new technology, and
started their own companies.
Others have won
national championships
or even courageously battled
a life-threatening illness.
All of us have persevered
through the hardships of life
at MIT and achieved greatness,
because when it came time
to choose between
giving up and hoping,
we made the right choice.
When that opportunity to
be a hero comes to you,
what will you do?
When a moment of
consequence arrives,
it is my hope that we
will relish that moment,
rise to the occasion,
and inspire by example.
We, the graduating
class of 2007,
may not be able to fly
or teleport ourselves.
But we don't need these special
powers to save the world.
In fact, we have something
much more important--
the hope that we can change
the future for the better.
All of us set to
graduate have struggled
to hold onto this hope despite
all that MIT has thrown at us.
But it's because of
the others here today--
our family, friends,
and teachers--
that it has remained strong.
And it's because of where we
are today, the place to which we
are now saying goodbye, that we
have the chance of fulfilling
our hopes and dreams.
When we give ourselves
something to look forward to,
no matter how great or small
the event, we are giving
ourselves hope.
When there is hope
built into tomorrow,
there are all kinds of
opportunities to overcome
the obstacles we face today.
In a short while, we will
walk across this stage
as MIT graduates, having
conquered our fears and doubts,
ready to save the world.
Today is a day of
great happiness.
We've survived the Institute,
and we have so much
to look forward to after today.
Thank you.
MEESE: And now, the moment
we've all been waiting for.
SHIN: For years we
have worn the Brass Rat
with the beaver sitting on
us, representing the hardships
imposed on MIT students.
Take one last look at
the Boston skyline, which
has symbolized the
outside world awaiting us,
and join me in turning
around your Brass Rat.
May the Cambridge skyline be a
constant reminder of your time
spent at MIT.
And now for the presentation
of the senior gift.
The average class participation
rate for four years
has been 33%.
I am proud to announce
that our class has
broken MIT's record with an
astounding 52% participation
rate.
A portion of the class gift
will go towards the class
of 2007's study abroad fund.
We hope that this fund
will help students
broaden their
educations and give them
a well-deserved break from MIT.
On behalf of the
senior class, I would
like to thank MIT Alumni
Association President Martin
Tang for matching our gift
with a generous $15,000.
Now I would like to ask
President Hockfield to join me
at the podium.
I'm honored to present
this check for $26,861
from the class of 2007 to you.
Congratulations, Class of 2007.
We made it!
HOCKFIELD: Thank you
very much, Class of 2007,
for the enthusiasm
that 52% represents.
Congratulations.
Graduates of MIT,
this is your day.
We have gathered
here in Killian Court
to celebrate your successful
completion of demanding courses
of study, and you have our
deepest respect for all
that you have accomplished.
But today is not yours alone.
None of you would
be here this morning
were it not for the
families and friends
who have nurtured
and supported you
since your childhood, who
have embraced your dreams
and lighted your path.
This is their day, too.
Graduates, I invite you
please to rise and to join me
in thanking your
families and friends.
Now, I want to speak to
those of you graduating today
about your path here at
MIT, and the path that
leads from MIT into the world.
Of course, before you arrived
here at MIT, each of you
had already demonstrated
significant talents.
That's why we invited you
to join our community.
Once you arrived here, you
took up MIT's challenges.
And working, I am certain,
harder than you ever
had before, you've taken
your academic accomplishments
to entirely new levels.
Today's ceremony is our
community's expression
of our pride and what
you have achieved.
Our appreciation of
your accomplishments
would be far too
narrow if included
only your academic successes.
Beyond the classroom
and the laboratory,
you have excelled on the stage
and on the playing field,
in service projects and
in entrepreneurship.
And what is perhaps
most important,
you have also begun to
distinguish yourselves
as leaders.
MIT itself has a deep
commitment to leadership,
demonstrated time and
again in myriad ways.
In the foundational science that
led to the new targeted cancer
therapies--
Gleevec for leukemia and
Herceptin for breast cancer.
In innovative plans to
rebuild devastated New Orleans
neighborhoods.
In countless businesses
from startups
in Kendall Square to industry
giants across the technology
landscape.
In fresh approaches to
meeting the world's energy
needs, including new
technologies for energy storage
and for solar energy conversion.
And in novel uses of technology
to convey the immortal truths
of the humanities.
And in many different ways, from
the UPOP program to the $100K
competition, from [? 2-007 ?]
to the Public Service Center,
our goal has been to teach
you how to become leaders
yourselves.
We have done this,
graduates of MIT,
because the world today
needs your leadership.
We need your
leadership as we face
the challenges of
an increasingly
complex and
interdependent world.
And we need your leadership
to develop new ways
to bridge old divides, not only
between peoples and nations,
but also between
technology and policy.
MIT's enduring motto, "Mens
et manus," "Mind and hand,"
is a reminder that leadership
in the modern world
depends critically
on integrating
across different perspectives
for the common good.
From one point of
view, the leadership
we call you to
assume today might
appear to be an obligation,
perhaps a burden.
But that would be
a grave mistake.
Leadership is a privilege
and it is a joy,
and I can assure you that in
using your talents to serve
others you will find
the most enduring
of personal satisfactions.
Even as you leave this place
to become your generation's
leaders, you will remain
members of this community.
At the close of this
morning's ceremony,
Martin Tang, the president
of the Alumni Association,
will formally welcome you into
the Association's membership.
And we hope that
your lives will be
enriched by an ongoing
connection to the Institute.
And it's my fervent hope that
as you join new communities,
you will transmit to them the
values that define the MIT
community; that you
will make integrity
the touchstone of
your judgments;
that you will exemplify
the pursuit of truth
and an unwavering
drive for excellence.
And that you will
continue to demonstrate
the value of good old
fashioned hard work.
Beyond these great
aspirations for you,
I make a more pressing request.
I ask of you to inspire your own
generation and the generations
to come with a renewed sense
of optimism for the future.
MIT's founding vision was
both practical and idealistic
in its insistence
that our work must,
as engraved across
the frieze of Lobby 7,
advance industry, the arts,
agriculture, and commerce.
That optimism for
a better future
has made MIT a beacon
visible the world over.
This weekend we will celebrate
MIT's optimism for the future
by re-igniting one of our
most powerful symbols.
After the late summer
sunset tomorrow
evening, for the first time
in more than three decades
we will fully relight
the great dome.
The lighting of the dome signals
the importance of what we do.
Here at MIT, we see
up close every day
the countless ways that
science and technology
benefit humankind.
But if we are to
realize our optimism,
we need to rekindle in others
the same love and passion
for truth and discovery, for
creativity and problem solving,
that brought us all here.
I hope that each of you
will embrace this challenge
as your own, that you will
let your light shine out
to illuminate the
paths for others.
Now, I would not set
you this challenge
if I did not think and
truly believe that you
could and would meet it.
I have tremendous faith in you.
Your intelligence, your
dedication, and your creativity
have inspired us
during your time here.
And I know that in the years
to come you will do even more,
and surprise and delight us
with your further achievements.
For your accomplishments
here at MIT,
I offer you my heartfelt
congratulations graduates
of MIT.
MEAD: Thank you,
President Hockfield.
And I should say, on behalf of
the Corporation , thank you.
Thank your faculty, your staff,
and the entire MIT community
for first, producing this
wonderful group of graduates,
and secondly, for a very
successful year of leadership
and excellence at MIT.
Congratulations.
We are finally there.
By virtue of the authority
delegated to them
by the Corporation
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
and on the recommendation
of the faculty,
President Hockfield
will now present the
following degrees.
Bachelor of Science, Bachelor
of Science, Master of Science.
Bachelor of Science,
Master of Engineering.
And the advanced degrees
for the School of Science
and Whitaker College of Health,
Sciences, and Technology.
Provost Reif will present
the advanced degrees
for the School of
Architecture and Planning,
the School of Engineering, the
School of Humanities, Arts,
and Social Sciences, and the
Sloan School of Management.
As they approach the ramp,
undergraduate degree recipients
will be greeted
by the chancellor,
the dean for student
life, and the dean
for undergraduate education.
Graduate degree
recipients will be
greeted by their school deans.
The first graduates
to be recognized
are the class marshals who
are seated on the stage.
PRESENTERS:
Recognition will now be
given to the offices
of the class of 2007,
and the offices of the
Graduate Student Council,
who are seated on the stage.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the School of Architecture
and Planning who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Art and Design
[READING NAMES]
Advanced degree
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the School of Architecture
and Planning who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Architecture.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science as
recommended by the Department
of Architecture.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Planning.
Master of Science in
Architecture Studies.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the School of Engineering
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Civil Engineering .
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Environmental Engineering
Science.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Building Technology
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science
in Visual Studies.
[READING NAMES]
Master in City Planning.
Bachelor of Science
as recommended
by the Department of Civil
and Environmental Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Mechanical Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTERS: Master of Science
in Urban Studies and Planning
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Media Arts and Sciences.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science without
specification of field.
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy, with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto.
[READING NAMES]
Advanced degree
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the School of Engineering
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Engineering in Civil
and Environmental Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Mechanical and Ocean
Engineering
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
and Engineering
as recommended by the Department
of Mechanical Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Civil
and Environmental Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Engineering
in Manufacturing.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Mechanical Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Material
Science and Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Naval Architecture
and Marine Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Archeology and Materials as
recommended by the Department
of Material Science
and Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science IN
Ocean Systems Management.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Electrical Science
and Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Engineering
in Material Science
and Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Material
Science and Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Engineering in
Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Electrical
Engineering and Computer
Science.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Chemical Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Chemical
Engineering Practice.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Aeronautics and Astronautics.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Computer
Science and Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Engineering in
Biomedical Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Toxicology.
Master of Science in Nuclear
Science and Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Engineering
in Logistics.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Computation
for Design and Optimization.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Engineering and Management.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Chemical Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Engineering Systems.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Technology and Policy.
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTERS: Bachelor of
Science in Chemical Biological
Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science
in Transportation.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science without
specification of field.
[READING NAMES]
Naval Engineer.
Engineer in Aeronautics
and Astronautics.
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Science with all
the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto.
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy, with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science, as
recommended by the Department
of Chemical Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Ocean Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Aerospace Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Aerospace Engineering
with Information Technology.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Nuclear
Science and Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the School of Humanities, Arts
and Social Sciences who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Economics.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Political Science.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Anthropology.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in History.
Bachelor of Science
in Literature.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Music.
Bachelor of Science in Writing.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Humanities.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Humanities and Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Humanities and Science.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Linguistics and Philosophy.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Comparative Media Studies.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the Sloan School of Management
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Management Science.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now
be presented to students
in the School of Science
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Chemistry.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Biology.
Advanced degree
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the School of Humanities, Arts,
and Social Sciences who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Science in
Comparative Media Studies.
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto.
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTERS: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be presented
to students in the Sloan
School of Management who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Business
Administration, Sloan Fellows.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
as recommended
by the Department of Biology.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Physics.
Master of Science and
Management, Sloan Fellows.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Business
Administration.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Brain
and Cognitive Sciences.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Earth, Atmospheric,
and Planetary Sciences.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Mathematics.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Mathematics
with Computer Science.
[READING NAMES]
Advanced degree
diplomas will now
be presented to students
in the School of Science
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Science in Physics.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Atmospheric Science.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science
in Mathematics.
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto.
[READING NAMES]
The Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution
and the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
offer joint programs of
education and research
in oceanography and applied
ocean science and engineering.
Dr. James A. Yoder, vice
president for academic programs
and Dean at the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution,
is here to participate
with President Hockfield
in awarding the
following joint degrees.
Master of Science in
Oceanographic Engineering.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Marine
Geology and Geophysics.
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto.
[READING NAMES]
Advanced degree
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the Whittaker College of Health
Sciences and Technology who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Science in
Biomedical Informatics.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Health
Sciences and Technology.
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Management.
Master of Science in
Management of Technology.
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Operations Research.
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto.
[READING NAMES]
MEAD: Congratulations to all
of the graduates of 2007.
It's now my pleasure
to introduce
Martin Tang, the Chief Marshal
who will greet the graduates.
Mr. Tang is a member
of the class of 1972,
and is currently serving as the
president of the Association
of Alumni and Alumnae of MIT.
Martin, please.
TANG: Thank you, Dana.
Good afternoon, all.
It it's my honor to
recognize the distinguished
class of 2007, the
newest alumni of MIT.
The entire alumni body,
now some 118,000 strong,
joins me in congratulating
all of the 2007 graduates,
and officially welcoming
you into the alumni
family, your infinite
connection to MIT.
Thank you.
MEAD: The 141st
commencement exercises
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
are now concluded.
A reception will now follow on
Kresge Oval on the West Campus
plaza.
And at this time, will the
stage assembly and the audience
please rise and join
the MIT Chorallaries
in singing the school song.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIT CHORALLARIES (SINGING):
Arise all ye of MIT,
in loyal fellowship.
The future beckons unto ye
and life is full and rich.
Arise and raise
your glass on high;
tonight shall ever
be a memory that
will never die for ye of MIT.
Thy sons and daughters, MIT,
return from far and wide
and gather here once more to
be renourished by thy side,
and as we raise our glasses high
to pledge our love for thee,
we join all those of days
gone by in praise of MIT.
Oh, I wish that I were
back again at Tech
on Boylston Street,
dressed in my dinky uniform
so dapper and so neat.
I'm crazy after calculus,
I never had enough;
so it's hard to be
dragged away so young,
it was horribly awfully tough!
Hurrah for technology,
'ology, 'ology,
oh, glorious old technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh!
Back in the days that
were free from care
in the 'ology varsity shop, with
nothing to do but analyze air
in an anemometrical top.
The differentiation of
the trigonometric powers,
the constant pi
that made me sigh
in those happy days of ours.
Hurrah for technology,
'ology, 'ology,
oh, glorious old technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh!
Take me back on a special train
to that glorious institute,
I yearn for the inspiration
of a technological toot.
I'd shun the quizzical physical
profs, the chapel and all that,
but how I'd love to go
again on a scientific bat.
La-la la-la, la-la la-la,
la-la-la la-la la la, la-la la
la.
La-la la-la.
Da, da-da-da!
La-la-la.
Da da.
Da-da, da-da, da-da, da-da!
Oh, M-A-S-S-A-C-H-U-S-E-T-T-S,
I-N-S-T-I-T-U-T-E O-F T-E.
And then it's C-H-N-O-L-O-G
and Y comes after G,
it's the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology!
Hey!
[MUSIC PLAYING]